bonjour à tous La séance est ouverte
donc l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au Gouvernement la première
d'entre elles va être posée par Pierre
Daredevil pour le groupe GDR
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre une réforme se prépare celle du
lycée professionnel qui concerne 28% des
lycéens leur formation migre de
l'éducation nationale vers le ministère
du Travail le doublement annoncé des
périodes de stage visa rapprocher cette
voie de celle de l'apprentissage et à
éviter qu'elle lui fasse trop de
concurrence ce sont 380 heures de cours
en moins au détriment de l'enseignement
général comme de l'enseignement
technique la réforme affaiblirait la
qualité de la formation le diplôme et
son caractère national le suivi des
jeunes en stage serait encore sacrifié
elle rendrait plus difficile l'accès à
des études supérieures en donnant le
pouvoir aux forces économiques sur la
formation de ces jeunes il s'agit de
promouvoir une logique de case à remplir
où le lycée professionnel formerait à
des tâches à usage immédiat et non plus
à des métiers la place de ces jeunes
n'est pas au travail dans l'entreprise
avec un patron s'ils ont la chance d'en
trouver un mais à l'école avec des profs
des copines et des copains une école qui
leur donne les moyens de comprendre
d'agir de s'épanouir dans toutes les
dimensions de leur vie ce projet
constitue un renoncement éducatif un
affaiblissement de l'action publique
pour les jeunes qui en ont le plus
besoin il va accentuer encore le tri
social ces jeunes ont droit comme le
disent Jean Jaurès à l'entière
croissance c'est pour eux que 62% des
personnels étaient en grève le 18
octobre un nouveau mouvement se prépare
le 17 novembre le malaise est très
profond dans un contexte de crise qui
frappe l'ensemble de l'éducation
nationale à l'heure où il faudrait
revaloriser les métiers du travail
manuel le lycée professionnel n'est-il
pas un lieu essentiel au cœur des grands
enjeux de la société et de ses mutations
des concertations ont péniblement été
lancés sur les modalités de mise en
oeuvre pas sur le bien fondé comment
sera débattu et décider démocratiquement
j'insiste démocratiquement l'avenir du
lycée professionnel
je vous remercie la parole est à madame
Carole Grandjean ministre délégué chargé
de l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
d'arriville vous nous interrogez sur le
projet de réforme du lycée professionnel
que nous portons avec le gouvernement
parce que oui nous nous avons
effectivement
chevillé au corps l'idée que la jeunesse
doit être préparée au défi de demain que
nous devons réformer un lycée
professionnel par lequel passe un tiers
de la jeunesse française un tiers de la
jeunesse française dont seulement 1/2
sincère effectivement dans l'emploi
alors oui nous partageons ce constat
avec les personnels pédagogiques et oui
nous devons répondre à ce défi pour
pouvoir accompagner chaque jeune dans
une réussite le lycée professionnel doit
être une voie d'excellence et nous
sommes convaincus de cela c'est pour
cela que nous avons engagé cette
concertation autour de quatre groupes de
travail c'est quoi quatre groupes de
travail ils viennent travailler sur le
décrochage il faut savoir que deux tiers
des décrocheurs viennent du lycée
professionnel et que c'est un
fondamental il vient travailler sur
l'insertion professionnelle et je vous
rappelle un sur deux diplômés de lycée
professionnel ne s'en sert pas dans
l'emploi et c'est notre responsabilité
et c'est celui du pacte républicain que
deux réponses à ce défi là et puis
seulement un élève sur deux qui poursuit
des études réussit effectivement dans la
poursuite d'études et donc c'est notre
responsabilité collective de mieux les
préparer donc ces groupes de travail ils
viennent préparer les conditions de
cette réussite ils viennent préparer
aussi les conditions de la réussite des
enseignants qui doit pouvoir
effectivement avoir les conditions
d'enseignement pour leur permettre
d'avoir des savoirs fondamentaux utiles
à leur parcours professionnel et à leur
parcours de citoyens ils doivent aussi
accompagner ses élèves qui sont dans une
orientation de de voix professionnelle
et donc ils doivent pouvoir être
préparés à un métier et une insertion
professionnelle écoutez je pense que
nous constatons tous ensemble que la
voix professionnelle ne tient pas
effectivement sa promesse républicaine
d'insertion professionnelle et donc tous
ensemble nous devons réfléchir aux
modalités qui permet à chacun
les élèves de réussir et c'est là tout
le défi que nous portons je vous
remercie
merci madame la ministre je demanderai à
tous les collègues d'observer un peu de
silence il y a un brouhaha constant et
on entend pas les orateurs c'est dommage
je ne désigne pas de coupable madame
Émilie bonivar pour le groupe les
républicain merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse au ministre de
l'Économie monsieur le ministre depuis
le mois de juin semaine après semaine
les députés les républicains vous
alertent sur les factures insoutenables
d'électricité de nos entreprises qui
risquent de les condamner purement et
simplement et avec elle des milliers
d'emplois dans notre pays depuis le mois
de juin nous vous disons que vous faites
fausse route en comptant sur une
solution européenne pour régler notre
problème depuis le 2 novembre nous en
avons désormais malheureusement la
confirmation l'Allemagne a annoncé
unilatéralement son dispositif grâce
auxquels ces entreprises verront leur
facture plafonnée à 130 euros le
mégawattheure pour 70% de leur
consommation
quand les entreprises françaises au
terme d'un calcul alambiqué ne
toucheront que quelques dizaines d'euros
pour subventionner un prix de marché
toujours aussi élevé exemple concret une
entreprise de matièrescription Closer
c'est vue proposer un contrat à environ
800 euros le mégawattheure avec l'aide
française elle continuera donc à payer
682 euros le mégawattheure soit 8 fois
plus que ce qu'elle paye actuellement là
où une entreprise allemande dans les
mêmes conditions de marché paiera 330
euros on passe du simple au double si
vous aviez obtenu une dérogation comme
les Espagnols et les Portugais en
subventionnant le prix du gaz destiné à
la production d'électricité mesure qui
nous aurait coûté 5 milliards donc
beaucoup moins coûteuses vous seriez en
mesure de proposer à nos entreprises un
prix moyen de marcher en France beaucoup
plus cohérent avec nos coûts réels de
production entre 50 et 70 euros le
mégawattheure
monsieur le ministre quand allez-vous
enfin reconnaître que la solution que
vous avez choisie n'est de toute
évidence absolument pas à la hauteur
pour nos entreprises et rectifier le tir
il y a
urgence on va dans le mur il en va de la
sauvegarde de milliers d'emplois dans
notre pays
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Agnès panière une
hachée ministre de la transition
énergétique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Bonivard je sais votre attachement aux
entreprises industrielles sur votre
territoire on a eu des combats communs
sur ces sujets là lorsque j'étais en
charge de l'Industrie et vous connaissez
également mon engagement ainsi que celui
de Bruno Le Maire et de Roland Lescure
qui se battent pour réindustrialiser
notre pays et qui ont obtenu des
résultats ces 5 dernières années
s'agissant de la question que vous posez
je veux d'abord redire une chose qui est
importante notre pays à la différence de
tous les autres pays européens disposent
d'un mécanisme qui a d'ailleurs été
discuté ici qui s'appelle la reine et
qui permet à une entreprise industrielle
d'avoir 50% de son électricité à un coût
de l'ordre de 50 euros du mégawatt ça
c'est pris en compte dans le tarif et
donc ça se verra sur la facture la
deuxième chose c'est sur la partie
complémentaire celle qui est exposée au
marché vous évoquez le cas d'une
entreprise qui se voit offrir un coup de
800 euros du mégawattheure pour cette
entreprise là nous allons amortir sur
50% de sa facture grosso modo 500 euros
entre 300 et 800 ça veut dire qu'elle
paiera 250 euros de moins sur cette
partie de sa facture alors bien sûr ça
part ça peut paraître compliqué mais
c'est très simple en réalité puisque
c'est sur la facture sans avoir à faire
de déclarations sans avoir à demander
quoi que ce soit que cet effort cet
amortisseur sera payé j'indique
également que s'agissant des ETI des
entreprises de taille intermédiaires et
des grandes entreprises elles peuvent
dès le 15 novembre déposer un dossier
pour leur permettre de bénéficier du
cadre des êtres détails Ukraine ce cadre
des aides détails Ukraine il s'appellent
à tous les pays de l'Union européenne à
l'Allemagne comme à la France et nous
allons l'utiliser pleinement et donc
comme nous accompagnerons nos
entreprises je vous remercie
la parole est un monsieur Arthur de la
porte pour le groupe socialiste
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre il ne s'agit pas de
mon patrimoine mais de celui de mes
enfants voilà ce qu'indiqué aux médias
d'un investigation disclose votre
ministre de la transition énergétique
selon cette enquête elle aurait
autorisée ses enfants mineurs à devenir
actionnaire d'une société dont les font
localisés dans des paris fiscaux
proviennent du numéro 2 du français du
pétrole depuis 4 ans pourtant à aucun
moment votre ministre de la transition
énergétique n'a modifié sa déclaration
d'intérêt pour le préciser ma question
est simple madame la Première ministre
aviez-vous connaissance de ces
informations quand vous l'avez nommé
ministre de la transition écologique si
ces informations sont confirmées quelles
conséquences en tirez-vous sur
l'exercice des fonctions de votre
Ministre
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
ma nièce panier rue nacher ministre de
la transition énergétique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
de la porte j'ai pris connaissance ce
matin des allégations fausses et
calomnieuses publiée par disclose je
tiens à naturellement à vous apporter
toute la transparence sur un sujet qui
n'a pas de lien avec mes fonctions de
ministres en 2016 mon père a souhaité
préparer sa succession par une
transmission directe assez petits
enfants cette transmission a eu lieu par
le biais d'une entreprise française
soumise à la fiscalité française par
acte notarié établi à Paris et dans le
plein respect des dispositions
applicables par la loi française il n'y
a donc rien de dissimulé rien de cacher
je précise que je ne bénéficie pas et de
bénéficierez jamais de ces fonds n'ayant
aucun droit présent ou futur sur cette
société
j'ai évidemment satisfait les
obligations déclaratives prévues par la
loi notamment auprès de la hatvp qui
prévoit expressément que les
déclarations de patrimoine ne concernent
pas le patrimoine des enfants y compris
mineur je précise également que mes
enfants n'ont pas touché d'argent de
cette société depuis sa création enfin
mon père
âgé aujourd'hui de 77 ans effectivement
travaillé depuis 1979 dans le secteur
pétrolier ce n'est un secret pour
personne pour ma part je n'ai aucun lien
avec la société Perenco ancien employeur
de mon père c'est en effet une société
étrangère qui existe qui exercent ses
activités pétrolières hors de France je
n'ai donc pas eu dans le cadre de mes
fonctions de ministres à connaître
d'activités de ce groupe mon père ma
mère et mes enfants n'ont pas choisi une
vie publique je l'ai choisi je la
conduis en pleine transparence sur mes
avoir comme sur mes intérêts et dans le
respect de la loi s'agissant de ma
famille et ce n'est pas la première fois
vous comprendrez bien que mon devoir est
de les protéger
je vous remercie madame la ministre
monsieur de la porte
un peu de silence s'il vous plaît
votre réponse madame la ministre n'est
évidemment pas satisfaisante la Haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publique souligne ainsi que l'absence
d'obligation déclarative ne dispense pas
le responsable public que vous êtes de
veiller à prévenir et faire cesser les
situations de conflit intérêts qui
naîtraient d'autres intérêts indirects
détenus telles que l'activité des
enfants ou d'autres membres de la
famille votre réponse circulez il n'y a
rien à voir nourri le sentiment de
défiance à l'égard de l'ensemble de la
classe politique en outre
les investissements de la société
évoqués que vous avez souligné à l'heure
de la COP 27 ne peuvent qu'interroger
sur votre position alors que vous êtes
en charge et dossiers énergétique nous
faisons face au plus grand défi de
l'humanité la crise climatique vous
voulez sortir des énergies fossiles en
même temps et vous étiez Perenco est
accusé d'atteinte à l'environnement aux
droits humains en République
démocratique du Congo et de
dissimulation fiscale certes votre père
est l'ancien dirigeant vos enfants en
sont indirectement actionnaires mais
votre position exigera davantage
d'explications que celle que vous venez
de nous fournir merci
c'est bon merci
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier Falorni
pour le groupe démocrate
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre de la Citoyenneté le
séparatisme est un danger majeur pour
notre République il y a bien sûr le
séparatisme islamiste mais il y a un
autre séparatisme c'est le séparatisme
sectaire le rapport de la misilud qui
vient d'être publié doit tous nous
alerter plus 33% en un an de signalement
pour des rives sectaires alors on y
retrouve ce que j'appelle les empires de
l'emprise c'est-à-dire ces sectes
multinationales qui sont de véritables
États dans l'état à l'image de
relationologie et qui ne cesse de
développer en France comme ailleurs leur
vaste entreprise d'asservissement mental
et financier mais en parallèle on
observe la prolifération de groupuscules
conspirationniste avec des gourous
ubérisés qui recrute leur victime sur
les réseaux sociaux et qui cible depuis
la pandémie les domaines de la santé et
du bien-être
alors dans tous les cas les conséquences
sont les mêmes
escroquerie a du sexuel
traumatisme psychologique et parfois
même d'essai car quand c'est gourous
deux points 0 un site par exemple à
remplacer la chimiothérapie par des jus
de légumes ou à se nourrir uniquement
d'air et de lumière je n'invente rien
alors oui on peut véritablement parler
de criminalité madame la ministre je
vous sais
attentif à ce sujet alors
qu'entendez-vous faire contre se
séparatisme sectaire qui bafoue les
valeurs de notre République et qui
s'attaquent au plus vulnérable de nos
concitoyens je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Sonia bacquez
secrétaire d'État chargé de la
citoyenneté même la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
député finorni effectivement le rapport
de la mi-vilud a mis en lumière
l'évolution inquiétante l'évolution
quantitative d'abord avec 4000 signes
signalements dont on sait très bien que
la plupart passe sous les radars que
c'est la partie émergée de l'iceberg
avec une évolution inquiétante sur un an
plus 33% plus 86% sur les six dernières
années donc une évolution quantitative
inquiétante et vous l'avez dit une
évolution aussi sur les modalités
d'emprise extrêmement inquiétantes on a
les multinationales et ces
multinationales continuent à être
scrutés suivi par l'ami vilud par le
ministère de l'Intérieur la Scientologie
les Témoins de Jéhovah il y a eu des
condamnations exercices illégales de la
pharmacie escroquerie en bande organisée
pour ce qui concerne la Scientologie
mais on a effectivement en parallèle
tout un tas d'autres gourous 2.0 qui
sont sans doute plus difficiles à suivre
en tout cas qui nous qui font qui
doivent faire évoluer également nos
Modalités de réponse c'est la raison
pour laquelle et ce sera une première
des Assises des dérives sectaires et du
complotisme seront organisés en début
d'année prochaine de manière à mettre
tous les acteurs qui sont concernés
autour de la table n'ont pas simplement
pour s'écouter mais pour mettre en place
un plan d'action réel pour travailler à
la fois sur la manière dont on signale
la manière dont on découvre et dont on
accompagne les personnes qui sont
concernées qui sont pour la plupart sous
emprise que ce soit une emprise physique
une emprise psychologique une emprise
parfois financière et puis de voir parce
que on a vu les difficultés qu'on a
rencontrées sur l'église de scientologie
et son installation à samedi peut-être
éventuellement voir s'il doit y avoir
des évolutions législatives pour nous
permettre d'avoir tous les outils sur le
sujet merci
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Aurélien saint
Toul pour le groupe la France insoumise
madame la Première ministre si l'on en
croit la presse votre ministre de la
transition énergétique coche toutes les
cases du bingo de l'oligarchie fraude
fiscale népotisme dissimulation et
conflit d'intérêts avec les industries
les plus polluantes elle est liée à une
société familiale ayant plus de 1
million d'euros dans des paradis fiscaux
elle a constitué un patrimoine à ses
enfants qui repose exclusivement sur des
actifs liés aux énergies fossiles elle a
choisi de ne pas déclarer ses intérêts à
la Haute autorité pour la transparence
de la vie publique elle a choisi de
mentir par omission elle savait
manifestement que c'était incompatible
avec ses fonctions la société familiale
en question opère dans des paradis
fiscaux Guernesey l'État américain du
dollaware l'Irlande Hong Kong etc les
actifs financiers détenus par la société
sont tous peu ou prouliés au groupe
berenco deuxième producteur français de
brut après total et dont Jean-Michel
runachet le père de Madame panier
renacher était jusqu'à récemment l'un
des dir historique c'est une entreprise
particulièrement opaque qui jusqu'en
2019 ne divulguait même pas son chiffre
d'affaires ni sa structure de
gouvernance partout ou Perenco
s'installe les scandales pleuvent
pollution dégradation environnementales
non respect des populations répression
des opposants et bien sûr absence totale
de transparence financière madame la
Première ministre vous avez refusé de
demander la confiance du Parlement et
encore aujourd'hui cette question de la
confiance se pose peut-on se fier à une
ministre qui considère que 1 million
d'euros de donation à ses enfants n'a
pas à figurer dans sa déclaration
d'intérêt peut-on croire en sa volonté
de sortir des énergies fossiles quand le
patrimoine de ses enfants est
directement lié à ses industries peut-on
se fier à une ministre qui constitue
pour ses enfants un patrimoine avec des
actifs domiciliés dans des paradis
fiscaux et vous même madame la Première
ministre pouvez-vous continuer à faire
confiance à
je vous remercie
Carole et à
mâle et renacher min
Istre une la présidente
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
député saint-oule monsieur le député
le député
à une certaine précaution sur ce que
vous avancez et vous indique quand toute
transparence mon avocat se tient à votre
disposition pour éclaircir les
différents points sur lequel vous
semblez
amalgamer un certain nombre d'éléments
donc en précision et en complément de ce
que je viens d'indiquer s'agissant d'une
société française qui paye ses impôts en
France dans le cadre d'une donation
exercée en France pour lequel la
fiscalité a été réglée en France selon
les règles fiscales françaises je pense
que c'est important de le dire qui s'est
déroulé en 2016 et qui n'a aucune
relation avec la société Perenco puisque
cette société est investie dans des
fonds qui sont disponibles sur étagère
et ouvert à des personnes qui gèrent
leur patrimoine mes enfants ne sont donc
en aucune façon actionnaire directement
ou indirectement comme vous semblez le
faire croire d'une société pétrolière
qui serait Perenco je vais pas rentrer
dans le détail mais ce que vous dites
est grave ce que vous dites est grave
monsieur le député ce que vous dites est
grave à un gouvernement qui a justement
pris la décision lors du quinquennat
précédent d'arrêter tout exploitation
pétrolifère en France ce qui part
construction interdit à cette société à
cette société d'exercer ses activités en
France ce que vous dites est grave parce
que tandis que vous interpellez en
essayant de faire le coup d'éclat cette
majorité travaille à sortir des énergies
fossiles cette majorité travaille par la
sobriété par la rénovation et
l'efficacité énergétique par
l'accélération
de les énergies renouvelables et par la
relance d'une filière nucléaire à sortir
des énergies fossiles madame ministre
la parole est à madame Béatrice Piron
pour le groupe Renaissance merci madame
la Présidente ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale monsieur le ministre je
souhaitais évoquer avec vous la
problématique des enfants en situation
de handicap la grande majorité d'entre
eux est-ce que l'arrivée dans nos écoles
souvent par choix de la famille parfois
par manque de place dans les
établissements spécialisés lorsque la
réalisation est rendue possible grâce
aux accompagnants d'élèves en situation
de handicap les aesh ils sont
aujourd'hui 132000 en augmentation à 42%
sur 5 ans et leur mission sont
fondamentales sans eux il n'y aurait pas
d'école inclusives notre majorité le
gouvernement ont déjà
œuvré pour améliorer leur situation
j'évoquerai notamment leur
professionnalisation avec une formation
à l'embauche puis une formation continue
renforcée la sécurisation de leur emploi
par des CDD de trois ans puis une CDI
dernièrement le versement de la prime
repérapus dans le budget 2023 nous avons
apprécié la création de 4000 nouveaux
emplois d'Ash en plus des 4000 déjà
actés lors de la rentrée dernière
puisque la rémunération des enseignants
sera revalorisée de 10%, les trois
groupes de la majorité vous ont donc
proposé un amendement de 80 millions
d'euros de revalorisation des aesh pour
que eux aussi bénéficient de 10%
d'augmentation à partir de la rentrée
prochainement qui a été retenu après le
49.3 et pour lequel vous avez levé le
gage et nous tenons à vous en remercier
Monsieur le Ministre cette avancement
rendra le métier d'avsh plus attractif
et cela au bénéfice des 430 000 élèves
en situation de handicap par ailleurs le
CNH Conseil national handicap doit se
réunir début 2023 et j'imagine que le
comité école inclusive pourra proposer
des aménagements dans l'organisation et
l'émission des ash que ce soit sur le
temps scolaire mais aussi périscolaire
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous nous
préciser ce que vous envisagez pour les
aesh mais aussi plus largement renforcer
l'offre pour les enfants en situation de
handicap afin d'améliorer leur accueil
et leur bien-être surtout je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur papendaye ministre de
l'Éducation et de la Genèse merci madame
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée Béatrice
Spiron la situation économique des aesh
et l'attractivité de leur métier sont en
effet déterminants pour la qualité et
l'effectivité de l'accueil des enfants
en situation de handicap dans le système
scolaire
l'engagement du ministère porte en effet
sur trois avancées majeures qui vont
améliorer la situation des aesh le
premier et vous l'avez souligné madame
la députée avec la première ministre
nous avons souhaité que le gouvernement
donne un avis favorable à la trois
amendements au PLF qui ont été portés
par les groupes Renaissance modem et
horizon qui permettront une augmentation
salariale de 10%
aux ash à partir du 1er septembre 2023
une enveloppe de 80 millions d'euros
supplémentaires a été réservé pour cela
deuxièmement cette revalorisation
s'ajoute à l'extension de la prime
replus destinée donc aux ESH et aux AED
en éducation prioritaire pour une somme
réservée au budget de 74 millions
d'euros troisièmement nous nous
engageons conformément aux engagements
du Président de la République à ce que
l'accès au temps complet des aesh soit
favorisés une ou travaillons pour cela
en lien avec les collectivités
l'objectif c'est bien d'aboutir à la
réussite éducative de tous les élèves et
pour cela nous travaillons à des
évolutions plus globales de l'école
inclusive que nous entendons proposer au
printemps prochain en lien avec ma
collègue Geneviève
dans le cadre de la Conférence nationale
du handicap notre objectif c'est bien
d'améliorer les conditions de travail
des aesh pour assurer le meilleur
accompagnement possible des enfants en
situation de handicap je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
Madame Julie le chanteur pour le groupe
rassemblement national
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur Darmanin ministre
de l'Intérieur et des autres mères
monsieur le ministre les faits divers se
succèdent mais un fait de société se
dessine Lola Justine Nadia et tant
d'autres sont les symboles de violences
exacerbées mettant en lumière la
faiblesse de la réponse judiciaire et
votre laxisme migratoire on en viendrait
parfois se demander si pour vous
protéger les Françaises est encore une
priorité
plutôt qu'une femme ne sort sans avoir
peur elle juge de tous les stratagèmes
baissez les yeux portez des écouteurs
elles doivent redoubler de vigilance en
boîte de nuit comme à deux pas de leur
porte grande cause perdue de ces deux
quinquennats les violences faites aux
femmes explosent en France une femme sur
deux a déjà subi des violences sexuelles
au moins une fois dans sa vie une grande
partie de ces agressions pourrait être
évitée les chiffres de votre ministère
le démontrent trop d'auteurs sont issus
illégale et incontrôlée récidiviste ou
visé par une qtf le discours du
président est incohérent admettant que
la moitié des faits de délinquance sont
liés à l'immigration irrégulière il
affirme pourtant que les deux ne sont
pas liés il faut expulser les
délinquants et criminels étrangers
notamment responsables de violences
envers les femmes les idéologies ne
respectant pas la liberté des femmes
n'ont pas leur place dans notre pays en
France l'égalité homme-femme ne se
négocie pas il faut montrer du courage
politique aggraver les peines encourus
par les agresseurs rétablir les peines
plancher inscrire au fichiers des
délinquants sexuels les harceleurs de
rue comme Marine le propose sans cesse
ce n'est pas aux Françaises d'adapter
leur tenue ou leur déplacements mais aux
étrangers de s'adapter aux lois de notre
République Monsieur le Ministre quand
allez-vous rendre aux Françaises leurs
droits à la sécurité quand
admettrez-vous que l'immigration
incontrôlée est un fléau pour la
sécurité des femmes entre autres et non
une chance comme beaucoup le prétendent
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
madame la Présidente et Messieurs les
député madame la députée permettez-moi
d'abord de corriger plusieurs choses que
vous évoquez dans votre polymère afin
que tous ceux qui nous écoutent ne
soient pas trompés par vos propos les
responsables d'acte mises en cause il
s'agit pas de décision de justice mais
mise en cause à l'intérieur c'est 18%
qui relèvent des personnes qui sont
étrangères et non pas la moitié des
faits et si vous voulez citer le
président de la République il leur a dit
que à Paris est dans les métropoles les
plus importantes il y a effectivement 45
à 50% d'actes délictuels ou criminels
commis par les étrangers mais que la
moyenne des actes criminels ou des
rituels commis par les étrangers sont
relèvent de 18%. deuxièmement vous
évoquez la question du harcèlement de
rue je pense qu'il aurait fallu à
l'époque que vous souteniez Marlène
Schiappa et la création la création du
délit justement de harcèlement de rue
avec l'action très importante c'est pas
les policiers et les gendarmes puisque
avec beaucoup de critiques à l'époque de
la création de ce dispositif nous
constatons aujourd'hui qu'il fonctionne
et qu'il fonctionne très bien d'ailleurs
la loi de modernisation du ministère de
l'Intérieur renforce les moyens et les
peines pour ce qui est du harcèlement de
rue on aura cette discussion sans doute
dans quelques jours troisièmement nous
constatons une augmentation de plus de
300 % de délinquants étrangers reconduit
à la frontière
3200 exactement depuis plus d'un an et
demi et je veux dire avec vous que nous
proposons dans le texte immigration un
certain nombre de levés de protection
subsidiaires qu'on aura l'occasion
d'évoquer voilà madame la députée ce que
j'allais vous signaler signaler
cependant que si le groupe du
Rassemblement national avait voté les
dispositifs législatif du garde des
sceaux et de nous-mêmes ça l'aurait
évité de jouer au pyromane pompier dans
l'hémicycle pour faire plaisir à leur
électorat
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Frédéric
valtoux pour le groupe horizon merci
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Madame la Ministre Sonia
Baqué chargé de la citoyenneté madame la
ministre le récent rapport de la Mission
interministérielle de vigilance et de
lutte contre les dérives sectaires déjà
évoqué montre que les saisines de la
mivilud ont atteint un triste record
l'année dernière force et de constater
que le phénomène des dérives sectaires
demeure plus que jamais prégné en France
n'épargnant aucun territoire et touchant
tous les domaines ces dérives sectaires
isolent ruines blesse et parfois tu la
crise sanitaire inédite que nous avons
traversé à favoriser l'émergence de
nouvelles mouvance et d'individus
souhaitant tirer profit des personnes
isolées malades ou en perte de repères
les dérives liées notamment à la santé
doivent réellement nous inquiéter au
pays de pasteurs de Laennec de Paris de
Paris de Charcot ou de Bichat et de tant
d'autres les gourous et autres
charlatans prolifèrent nous parlons ici
d'un danger majeur en termes de santé et
de sécurité publique un danger vital il
est inconcevable de laisser proférer des
pseudothérapeutes de malheurs qui
mettent en péril autant de vie en 2015 à
l'initiative de son ancien président
Serge blisco la mi-vilud avait signé un
protocole avec l'Ordre des médecins il
faut sans doute aller plus loin dans
l'application des ordres professionnels
en matière de lutte contre le Sharan le
charlatanisme pardon et les dérives
sectaires pendant plusieurs années la
mi-vilud n'était plus qu'une priorité
aujourd'hui notamment grâce au travail
du ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald Damart
Darmanin que je tiens à saluer le
président de la République et le
gouvernement ont renforcé les moyens de
cette organisme essentiel pour lutter
contre l'ensemble de ces dérives
sectaires il faut désormais aller plus
loin aussi j'ai deux questions
pouvez-vous d'abord nous indiquer
comment le gouvernement compte renforcer
son action
la matière quelles initiatives et dans
quel calendrier par ailleurs concernant
les dérivés à la santé comment renforcer
les contrôles permettre une meilleure
coopération entre tous les acteurs
concernés ainsi qu'une meilleure
information du public qui est
essentielle je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Sonia
baquet ministre en charge de la
citoyenneté merci les députés monsieur
le députés Valtou j'ai déjà répondu tout
à l'heure en partie à la question du
député fireny pour vous dire
qu'effectivement il y a des nouvelles
formes qui se développent qui sont sans
doute en partie liées au covid d'abord à
l'isolement d'un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens et ensuite à la remise en
cause de manière plus systématique du
fait scientifique je voudrais profiter
de cette réponse pour indiquer au
rassemblement national qu'un certain
nombre de leurs responsables m'ont
accusé de nazisme de vouloir mettre en
place un ministère de la Vérité parce
que j'ai simplement dit que c'était un
geste qui sauve de signaler quand on a
quelqu'un qui est en train de partir
dans ces formes séparatisme parce que en
2021 c'est un jeune qui est décédé suite
à 21 jours de jeunes hydrique parce que
ce sont des gens qui sont décédés à la
suite d'un arrêt de chimiothérapie pour
les remplacer par des jus de légumes ou
du respirianisme c'est ça la réalité
donc il ne s'agit pas chacun a le droit
de penser ce qu'on veut il n'y a pas et
il n'y aura pas de délit de complotisme
simplement c'est souvent et
malheureusement très souvent le
complotisme qui est à l'origine de leur
de l'entrée dans ces formes de dérive
sectaires donc pour répondre à votre
question monsieur le député et je l'ai
dit des assises et ce sera la première
fois des assises et des rives sectaires
et du complotisme seront mises en place
l'année prochaine nous avons déjà fait
retirer à doctolib 6000 références de
naturopathe ou pseudo naturopathe qui
n'étaient pas reconnu agréé par le
Ministère de la Santé nous continuons ce
travail au quotidien pour identifier
ceux qui parmi ces différents praticiens
sont des charlatans et nous continuerons
bien évidemment avec l'aide de la
cellule qui est mise en place au niveau
de la direction générale de la police
nationale la kemade qui fait un travail
extraordinaire d'enquête sur le sujet je
vous remercie
je vous remercie madame la ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Louis Bricout
pour le groupe liotte merci madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
hier le président de la République
s'exprimé à la cop27 j'ai entendu avec
satisfaction la volonté de renoncer
l'exploitation des fonds marins mais
j'ai entendu aussi pour le reste un
président donné des leçons au monde
entier une posture quelque part en
décalage avec nos propres résultats
comme si nous étions nous-mêmes
exemplaire comme si vos politiques
étaient la hauteur des enjeux j'ai
surtout entendu un président quelque
part en mode avion déconnecté des
réalités écologiques en France des
déconnecter des territoires
la planification écologique aurait dû
s'inscrire puissamment
dans le budget 2023 tel n'est pas le cas
combien de propositions repoussées
combien d'amendements balayés combien de
49-3 quand allez-vous véritablement vous
engager avec nous dans la lutte par
exemple contre la précarité énergétique
je vous proposais il y a 3 ans avec mon
collègue Boris Vallot d'agir
concrètement sur les passoires
thermiques avec une approche globale et
performante des rénovations avec un
suivi renforcé des dossiers précaires et
surtout un financement innovant par une
subvention forfaitaire d'une part et le
reste à charge sous la forme d'une
avance remboursée à la mutation du bien
à la vente ou la succession
comme sur d'autres enjeux je pense à la
mobilité propre mais aussi l'agriculture
êtes-vous prête à travailler à des
solutions concrètes et communes alors
que la planète joue sa survie il n'y a
plus de place pour les beaux discours il
nous faut nous entendre tous il est
temps maintenant de faire ensemble
êtes-vous prêt à être madame la Première
ministre a passé des paroles aux actes
je vous remercie monsieur le député la
parole est à Madame Agnès panière une
hachée ministre de la transition
énergétique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Bricout je vais d'abord dire
qu'effectivement le président de la
République
ah pardon je vais chercher tes yeux que
le Président de la République apporté un
propos fort à la cop27 un propos qui est
non seulement ambitieux mais qui est
incarné incarné dans des actions qui
sont portées par la France qui sont
portés par l'Union européenne je veux
rappeler ici que c'est l'Union
européenne qui aujourd'hui a pris les
décisions et à l'objectif de réduction
de ces gaz à effet de serre le plus
ambitieux de l'ensemble des continents
de la planète c'est aujourd'hui l'Union
européenne qui a l'ensemble de textes le
plus contraignant pour permettre
d'atteindre ses objectifs ambitieux de
réduction de gaz à effet de serre je
veux également dire que le Président de
la République s'est engagé sur les
financements à apporter au pays en
développement qui sont les plus
vulnérables et qui font face aux
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
6 milliards d'euros chaque année porté
par la France 2 milliards d'euros pour
l'atténuation beaucoup de pays ne
peuvent pas en dire autant je veux
encore dire ici que le Président de la
République a fait très clairement du
lien entre le réchauffement climatique
et la biodiversité une condition de la
réussite de ces négociations et c'est en
ce sens qu'il a qu'il s'est engagé à
mettre en place des contrats de
partenariat biodiversité avec des grands
pays comme le Gabon et la lombie mais
également qu'il soutient l'interdiction
de l'exploitation des grands fonds
marins dans tous les océans tout ça est
très concret et tout ça est très concret
en France je l'ai dit à l'instant notre
transition énergétique elle s'incarne
dans une stratégie où il y a quatre
éléments la sobriété énergétique nous
avons un plan de sobriété énergétique il
est fait pour durer et nous devons
réduire de 10% notre consommation
d'énergie dans les deux ans qui viennent
un plan d'efficacité énergétique qui j'y
reviendront avec la loi hygiène
énergique climat merci beaucoup
maintenant sur les eénères et un plan
sur le nucléaire merci beaucoup monsieur
Bricout
merci Madame les ministres de votre
réponse mais bien sûr le la COP 27 doit
être un cadre et des ambitions mais on
ne doit pas habiller de je pense notre
feuille de route je vous le répète le
temps des plus au discours au beau
discours il faut agir vite concrètement
et ensemble surtout
madame Éléonore carroa pour le groupe
Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Madame Laurence Boone
secrétaire d'État auprès de la ministre
des Affaires étrangères chargées de
l'Europe le 30 octobre lucination Louna
Da Silva a remporté les élections
présidentielles au Brésil avec 50,9% des
voix devant son de très peu jaillir
wolsonaro nous avons assisté à
l'élection présidentielle la plus serrée
du Brésil depuis la fin de la dictature
militaire de 1985 Emmanuel Macron a été
l'un des premiers chefs d'État et le
félicité pour sa victoire à peine
quelques minutes après l'annonce des
résultats il a indiqué à tendre avec
beaucoup d'impatience de pouvoir
relancer un partenariat stratégique à la
hauteur de notre histoire et des défis
qui sont devant nous
la France et le Brésil entretiennent en
effet des relations fortes et très
anciennes leur relation économique
étroite se traduit par une importante
présence française au Brésil avec
environ 1000 entreprises françaises qui
emploie plus de 500 000 personnes la
France et le Brésil partage également la
frontière la plus longue française qui
est celle de la Guyane après trois ans
de relation bilatérale en berne la
communauté franco-brésilienne se réjouit
de la volonté de nos deux pays de
renouer activement leur lien d'amitié
leur dialogue politique et leurs
échanges mais il reste désormais à
déterminer les axes prioritaires de
cette coopération retrouvée alors que la
déforestation et les feux de forêt se
sont multipliés sous la présidence de
Jahid wolsonaro en 2022 il s'agissait de
1 million cinq 1.5 millions d'arbres
soit près de 4000 terrains de football
par jour abattu par jour Lula affirmait
que le Brésil et la planète ont besoin
d'une Amazonie en vie dès lors madame la
secrétaire d'État chargée de l'Europe
quelles actions la France pourrait-elle
entreprendre à court terme afin de
renouer son parten la stratégique
d'autre part l'élection de Lula est
perçue comme un signal positif pour
l'avancée du traité
UE melkosuge madame la secrétaire d'État
la France est-elle favorable à la
reprise des négociations et de quelle
manière le gouvernement prévoit-il de
s'assurer que ce nouvel accord tienne
compte des exigences en matière
environnementale et la nécessité d'un
développement je vous remercie la parole
est à Madame Laurence bonne secrétaire
d'État chargé de l'Europe
madame la Présidente et Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés et Madame la
Députée Éléonore carvoy tout d'abord je
vous prie d'excuser Catherine Colonna
qui ne peut être ici aujourd'hui
puisqu'elle est à la COP 27 que l'on
vient d'évoquer sur l'accord avec le
Mercosur plusieurs tas dont la France
ont posé des exigences strictes et
demandez il est rentré monsieur et
demander à la Commission européenne des
engagements additionnels sur la
protection du climat et la protection de
l'environnement ces demandes sont bien
évidemment conformes à la nouvelle
approche de l'Union européenne en
matière de commerce et de développement
durable comme nous en avons discuté ici
union qui fixe nos exigences sociales et
environnementales
vous avez mentionné la lutte contre la
déférent la déforestation pardon et
c'est effectivement un enjeu majeur en
Amérique latine et là à la fois la
France et l'Union européenne ont répondu
la France en 2019 avec l'Alliance pour
la préservation des forêts tropicales et
humides qui comptent aujourd'hui 32
membres et plus récemment la coalition
de haute ambition pour la nature et les
peuples qui réunit sans état
nous soutenons aussi les travaux en
cours sur le projet de réglementation
européenne sur la lutte contre la
déforestation
dans ce contexte et vous l'avez
mentionné la victoire de Lula au Brésil
est effectivement une excellente
nouvelle pour nos relations bilatérales
et comme vous le disiez le président de
la République immédiatement parler au
président élu pour le féliciter et
exprimer sa volonté de relancer nos
relations avec le Brésil qui est un
partenaire incontournable en Amérique
latine en plus d'être notre voisin comme
vous le soulignez avec les frontières
nous avons avec le Brésil des intérêts
communs sur le climat sur la protection
de l'environnement et de l'Amazonie en
particulier sur la promotion des droits
économiques et sociaux ou la défense du
multilatéralisme et nous attendons avec
impatience les mois à venir pour
préciser les contours d'une feuille de
route commune merci merci beaucoup
madame la ministre la parole est à
madame la Présidente châtelain pour le
groupe écologiste
madame la Première ministre de nouveau
je vous interroge sur les
responsabilités que vous avez confiées à
la ministre de la transition énergétique
elles sont fondamentales puisqu'il lui
revient de préparer mettre en oeuvre la
politique du gouvernement dans les
domaines de la transition énergétique
ainsi que de préparer de mettre en œuvre
la politique de réduction des émissions
gaz à effet de serre les révélations du
site discloses médias d'investigation
indépendants sont de nature à
questionner la capacité de la ministre à
exercer ses fonctions de manière
impartiale et à faire primer l'intérêt
général en effet la ministreur 2016 un
document permettant à ses enfants
mineurs de devenir actionnaire et ritier
d'une société dont les fonds sont situés
dans des paradis fiscaux et qui
entretient des liens étroits avec la
société Perenco deuxième producteur
français de pétrole brut ainsi madame la
Première ministre pouvez-vous nous
confirmer que la ministre a signé ce
document qui est la sciemment omis cette
information lors de ses déclarations
d'intérêt de patrimoine successifs en
2018 en il va et en 2022 et dans ce cas
lui renouvelez-vous votre confiance
je vous remercie
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la Présidente là alors vous auriez pu
m'interroger sur la cop27 dans
lesquelles l'ensemble des pays de la
planète doit se retrouver pour porter
une ambition forte pour réduire nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre vous
pourriez aussi m'interroger sur notre
politique énergétique qui est au
croisement d'enjeux majeur de
souveraineté de réduction de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
pouvoir d'achat de compétitivité de
notre économie si votre propos est de
commenter des articles de presse je vous
dis que mon rôle n'est pas de commenter
des articles de presse et que la
ministre a déjà eu l'occasion de
s'exprimer sur le sujet je vous remercie
je vous remercie
je vous remercie madame la Présidente
vous l'avez dit la politique énergétique
de la France est cruciale c'est pourquoi
il ne peut subsister aucun doute qu'elle
est pris dans l'intérêt des Français et
non pas dans des intérêts particuliers
aujourd'hui au vu de l'urgence
climatique ces intérêts individuels font
porter un grave discrédit sur l'action
duvet du gouvernement qui n'est déjà
clairement pas à la hauteur comment
croire que vous êtes déterminé à mener
une politique de sortie des énergies
fossiles quand la ministre semble
influencé dans l'exercice de ses
responsabilités madame la Première
ministre en tant que haute fonctionnaire
je connais votre attachement à la
probité et à l'éthique allez-vous exiger
de la ministre qu'elle mettre un terme à
ses conflits d'intérêts qui font porter
atteinte à notre politique énergétique
c'est bon merci
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
merci madame la Présidente alors je
crois que nous sommes dans un hémicycle
pas dans un tribunal madame la
Présidente
et si vous vous intéressez à la
politique énergétique de notre pays
voyage j'aurais pu vous parler du projet
de loi qui a été adopté à la fin de la
semaine dernière au Sénat pour accélérer
le développement des énergies
renouvelables je pense qu'avec le texte
présenté la semaine dernière sur
l'accélération du développement du
nucléaire c'est un texte fondamental
pour tenir notre feuille de route de
sortir au plus vite des énergies
fossiles moi je note qu'au Sénat ce
texte a été voté par le groupe les
républicains par le Centre par la
majorité présidentielle par le groupe
écologique et par les socialistes et je
vous confirme que nous souhaitons
travailler avec vous pour améliorer
encore ce texte c'est ce qui intéresse
les Français et c'est ce sur quoi mon
gouvernement est mobilisé je vous
remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Marc Le Fur
pour le groupe les républicains
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
qui me répondra peut-être puisque je
l'interroge sur le fond des choses
avec vous Madame la première ministre le
pouvoir d'achat de nos compatriotes
baisse avec vous la voiture qui était
jusqu'à présent un bien accessible est
en train de devenir un produit de luxe
or pour beaucoup de familles la voiture
est indispensable cela vaut pour le
monde rural mais pas seulement prenons
une famille le papa la maman travaille
ils ont chacun besoin d'un véhicule et
pour peu qu'il y ait des jeunes adultes
à la maison qui étudient qui sont dans
l'apprentissage il leur faut aussi un
véhicule cela fait trois véhicules dans
la famille l'actuel croissance très
importante des prix pénalise ce type de
famille et vous êtes pour partie
responsable en ayant fait le choix de
désorganiser le marché en multipliant
les normes et les malus aujourd'hui le
prix moyen d'une voiture neuve et de 26
800 euros et vous avez également fait le
choix de désorganiser les marchés pour
longtemps en allant vers le tout
électrique à marche forcée quel que soit
les aides publiques la voiture
électrique reste et restera plus cher
que la voiture thermique c'est un saut
dans
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Le Fur même si pour cette question de
fond en effet vous nous prêtez des
pouvoirs importants je ne crois pas que
nous soyons en train désorganiser le
marché en revanche je partage avec vous
la nécessité d'accompagner les Français
c'est ce que nous avons fait avec
lucidité et cohérence vous avez parlé de
pouvoir d'achat il était indispensable
en effet nous l'avons assumé quitté
affronté des critiques sur le volet
écologique de soutenir les Français face
à l'explosion les prix du carburant mais
on fait comme aucun pays en Europe
pourquoi parce que si nous l'avions pas
fait nous aurions empêché la transition
écologique en piégeant des Français dans
l'usage quotidien qui est nécessaire de
la voiture pour aller au travail et pour
vivre leur vie mais nous devons aussi
continuer à préparer l'avenir et d'aider
les Français des notes industrie à faire
cette transition il ne serait pas sage
et je crois qu'il ne serait rendre
service ni à notre industrie ni aux
Français dont je voudrais l'écrit le
quotidien de faire l'impasse sur cette
transition et sur cette transformation
essentielle alors nous avons agi nous
avons fixé les règles au niveau européen
pour ne pas avoir des règles françaises
qui seraient plus dures que celles de
nos voisins nous avons fix que cet
objectif nous l'assumons nous l'avons
porté 2035 le véhicule thermique seront
interdits à la vente en Europe cela est
très proche et nous devons l'accompagner
par une politique de souveraineté et une
politique de pouvoir d'achat une
politique de souveraineté ça veut dire
que si on veut que ce ne soit pas des
véhicules chinois ou l'Union Européen
qui soit ainsi acheté il faut contrôler
sur notre sol à des conditions de
compétitivité de compétences qui sont
les nôtres j'étais hier à Dunkerque nous
allons ouvrir grâce à l'accompagnement
public notamment celui de l'État une
usine de 2000 emplois d'ici deux ans qui
fabriquera des batteries électriques et
nous aurons l'indépendance d'ici 2027 en
matière de batterie électrique
aujourd'hui les véhicules électriques
sont trop chers vous avez raison nous
avons renforcé les aides et nous
continuerons sur le déploiement des
bornes sur l'acquisition directe du
véhicule électrique pour faire baisser
les prix et développer aussi
progressivement un marché de l'occasion
c'est le cas du bonus que nous avons
augmenté à 7000 euros pour les ménages
les plus modestes c'est le cas du prêt à
taux zéro dans les adefe c'est le cas de
la prime à la conversion c'est le cas du
microcrédit tous ces dispositifs sont
importants suite à votre disposition
pour que nous en discussion pour les
renforcer avec Agnes
pour cent dans le budget 2023 sur ce
dispositifs merci beaucoup Monsieur Le
Fur merci
vous exprimez des principes abstraits
nous défendons les intérêts des gens des
vrais gens de ceux qui ont directement
concernés par les aléas de votre
politique et puisque vous avez monsieur
le ministre dit des choses sur le
contrôle technique des motos pourquoi
pas monsieur le fils il y a des choses à
dire sur le contrôle technique
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Carlos Martens
bilongo pour le groupe la princesse
soumise
je vous remercie à demain présidente
mesdames messieurs les ministres chers
collègues les dommages causés par le
restaurant climatique sont déjà une
réalité heureusement climatique cause
des dégâts considérables et des
catastrophes vont les pays les plus
vulnérables les phénomènes
météorologiques extrêmes ont tué plus de
410 000 personnes et affecter 1,7
milliards de personnes dans le monde les
pertes et dommages dont stimulées entre
290 et 580 milliards de dollars dans les
pays on voit de développement d'ici à
2030 c'est dommage tous principalement
des pays qui ne sont pas responsablement
climatique et ont eu moins de capacités
financières pour y répondre dans ce
contexte plusieurs de ces pays ont
réclamé la création d'un fonds de perte
et dommage il s'agirait d'un fonds de
compensation conséquences irréversible
changement climatique les pays les plus
pollueurs ont une dette envers les pays
les moins les plus touchés par les
conséquences du dérèglement climatique
il est temps que cette dette soit
reconnue jusqu'à présent la France
refuse de participer aux paysans de la
dette climatique et s'oppose à la
création de ce fond mais en seulement 24
heures l'industrie des inerties fossiles
génèrent les super profits 200 fois
supérieur à tous les financements dédiés
pour parler gouvernements pour remercier
à ces dommages les profits générés par
cette industrie couvriraient même 60
fois le coût total des dégâts causés par
règlement climatique les fonds existent
la volonté politique non Emmanuel Macron
a déclaré dans son discours à
l'ouverture de la COP 27
les injustices du son du monde dans
lequel nous vivons sont devenus
insoutenables les crises aggravent ces
injustices ne pouvons-nous en sortir que
par nos fondations profondes de
mécanique de solidarité publique et
privé et des règles qui sont les nôtres
que quand est-ce que vous passerez des
paroles aux actes la France
soutiendra-t-elle la création d'un fond
perdomases à l'occasion de la COP 27
si mon cher collègue la parole est à
Madame
Agnès panière une hache et ministre de
la transition énergétique merci madame
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député bilongo merci
pour cette question qui pose
effectivement un sujet important
s'agissant des actions de solidarité en
direction des pays les plus volumérables
qui sont confrontés un impact du
réchauffement climatique comme je le
disais tout à l'heure il y a trois
conditions de la réussite des
négociations de cette coop la première
condition c'est que les pays qui sont
fortement émetteurs réhausse leur
objectif nous le faisons en France nous
le faisons en Europe nous voulons que
tous les pays le fassent c'est une façon
aussi de préserver ces pays qui sont
vulnérables et qui ne sont pas à
l'origine du réchauffement climatique la
deuxième condition c'est celle qui vous
que vous mentionnez c'est d'accompagner
les pays qui font face à ce
réchauffement climatique il y a pour ça
deux politiques vous les connaissez
celles qui permettent à ces pays de
s'adapter au réchauffement climatique de
faire évoluer leur agriculture de faire
évoluer leur infrastructure pour
permettre de ne pas être
victime d'événements climatiques subis
ou d'événements publics climatiques
soudain ou d'événements climatiques qui
se construisent dans la durée par
exemple une sécheresse durable mais
c'était pour ça que la France mais deux
milliards d'euros sur cette adaptation 2
milliards d'euros au service des pays en
développement et notamment avec l'Agence
française de développement qui est un de
nos bras armés et dont la qualité des
interventions est aujourd'hui reconnues
notamment dans les pays africains
j'étais également à la précop à Kinshasa
et j'ai eu des retours très positifs sur
le programme adaptation enfin vous avez
mentionné le sujet des pertes et
dommages sur ce sujet là je veux d'abord
dire que la France et l'Union européenne
font partie des pays qui ont forcé dans
l'agenda le fait que ce point soit
traité à la cop27 ce n'était pas du tout
gagné et c'est la position de la France
et de l'Union qui l'a permis ça a été
une nuit de négociation entre dimanche
et lundi rappelons aussi les choses
importantes je veux également dire si la
France merci beaucoup
monsieur bilan go
la France a un rôle à jouer au niveau du
climat et il faut aller vraiment au bout
des discussions et surtout avec les pays
en voie de développement quand on se
rend compte que la Méditerranée et les
pays sont vraiment en danger et on est
devant de grosses conséquences qui
risquent d'arriver
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Stella Dupont pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre du Travail vous
avez au côté du ministre de l'Intérieur
annoncé quelques grandes lignes de la
loi immigration à venir un aspect
primordial de ces annonces vise à
remettre le travail au centre du jeu
monsieur le ministre il nous faut sortir
de l'hypocrisie telle que le
gouvernement le propose aujourd'hui
c'est essentiel il nous faut sortir de
l'ornière d'une image négative trop
souvent véhiculée autour de
l'immigration la France est un pays
d'immigration politique humanitaire
culturelle mais aussi économique bien
entendu qu'on ne peut pas accueillir la
terre entière et qu'il faut des limites
fermes envers ceux qui ne sont pas
autorisés à demeurer dans notre pays
mais à Angers comme partout en France
nous sommes confrontés à une réalité
d'emploi non pourvu de tension sur de
nombreux bassins d'emploi et qui nuitent
à l'activité de nos entreprises et
parallèlement à ces difficultés de
recrutement nous avons les étrangers qui
sont en capacité de travailler ou qui
travaillent qui travaillent parfois en
situation irrégulière sortons de
l'hypocrisie oui vous vous attaquez au
problème à la racine c'est l'ADN de la
majorité les titres de travail sur les
métiers en tension sont une piste
vraiment intéressante et que nous
attendions monsieur le ministre comment
comptez-vous associer les partenaires
sociaux syndicats patronat puisqu'une
telle évolution bien entendu doit être
co-construite et doit se faire dans une
logique de responsabilité et de progrès
social pour tous pouvez-vous nous
préciser vos axes de travail et la
méthode que vous envisagez pour avancer
sur ce sujet qui peut et qui est déjà
instrumentalisé par une partie de la
classe politique à droite et à l'extrême
droite alors que le sujet est important
pour nombre de d'étrangers pour nombre
d'entreprises nous avons absolument
besoin d'avancer nous y sommes prêts
vous y êtes nous sommes à vos côtés
merci
appliquer les décisions il y a aussi la
volonté d'intégrer les étrangers
présents sur notre territoire par le
travail cela passe par des
simplifications notamment en matière
d'accès au travail de dispense de
demande d'autorisation pour les immigrer
au titre de la vie économique cela passe
aussi par la possibilité que nous
voulons ouvrir de permettre à des
travailleurs aujourd'hui irréguliers
mais exerçant dans des secteurs en
tension de recrutement de pouvoir
connaître une admission exceptionnelle
au séjour sur le modèle de ce qui est
fait par la circulaire de 2012 que l'on
qualifie parfois de circulaire Valls
pour reprendre le nom du ministre de
l'Intérieur de l'époque est-ce qu'il
s'agit régularisation massive non il
s'agit d'études au cas par cas en
fonction de l'ancienneté sur le
territoire et de l'occupation d'un
emploi dans des métiers en tension il
s'agit d'apporter des réponses des
réponses à des chefs d'entreprise qui
recrutent mais des réponses aussi à des
hommes et des femmes qui sont intégrés
travaillent sur notre territoire
souhaitent continuer à le faire dans des
bonnes conditions il s'agit
d'accompagner les employeurs mais aussi
les salariés concernés puisque en
permettant à ses salariés de demander
eux-mêmes leur régularisation à ce titre
nous pouvons dans des cas extrêmement
minoritaires mais qui existent les
soustraire à la domination de certains
employeurs qui peuvent être indélicats
je répète ces minoritaires mais ça
existe nous allons faire avec le
Parlement avec les syndicats et avec les
associations merci Monsieur le Ministre
la parole est à Madame Karine Lebon pour
le rôle
merci madame la Présidente tout d'abord
je souhaite rendre hommage à Charlotte
DALO qui a été poignardée à mort par son
conjoint dimanche à La Réunion cette
femme de 49 ans laisse derrière elle
trois enfants je pense à elle et à ses
proches
ma question s'adresse au ministre de
l'éducation nationale aujourd'hui à deux
jours de la Journée nationale de lutte
contre le harcèlement scolaire combien
de jeunes souffrent de moqueries répétés
sur leur poids leur tenue vestimentaire
leur couleur de peau leur orientation
sexuelle combien s'absente de leur
établissement scolaire combien
s'auto-mutile combien choisissent
malheureusement d'en finir car ils n'ont
plus la force de faire face à la Réunion
il s'agit d'un enfant sur 8 c'est 1 sur
10 sur l'ensemble du territoire sur les
trois premiers mois de l'année les
passages aux urgences pour des
tentatives de suicide d'adolescents ont
augmenté de 25% par rapport à la même
période en 2021 le confinement y est
certainement pour beaucoup mais cela
montre que nous n'avons plus le temps
monsieur le ministre loin d'envoyer un
bon signal la disparition des
infirmières scolaires est extrêmement
préoccupante elles étaient un relais
essentiel
même constat du côté des psychologues
scolaires des dizaines de postes sont
non pourvus dans les académies la loi du
3 mars 2022 n'est pas suffisante la
réponse punitive ne peut pas être la
seule solution la prévention et la
sensibilisation sont capitales on
s'appuie trop sur des enseignants
volontaires un échantillon à qui on
demande toujours plus sans lui donner
les outils et le temps le programme
phare est obligatoire depuis septembre
dans les écoles et collèges les
formations doivent commencer ce mois-ci
pouvez-vous me confirmer que vous êtes
dans les temps que tous les
établissements fait remonter la liste de
leurs ambassadeurs et personnels
concernés et surtout quand comptez-vous
lancer des formations obligatoires à ce
sujet pour tous les enseignants je vous
remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Papen Diagne ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la député
le bon vous l'avez rappelé la Journée
nationale de lutte contre le harcèlement
à l'école est prévu dans deux jours
j'étais moi-même hier en compagnie de
Madame Macron et de mes collègues
Charlotte cobel et Franck Riester dans
un collège de Seine-et-Marne où nous
avons pu saluer le travail des élèves
lauréats du Prix non harcèlement je vous
invite d'ailleurs à voir leur clip vidéo
par ailleurs le Parlement c'est en effet
saisi de cette question par la loi du 2
mars 2022 et de notre côté nous avons
généralisé le programme phare en cette
rentrée mais je me permets de corriger
votre propos le programme PHARE ça n'est
pas de la répression c'est de la
formation c'est de la sensibilisation
avec les 10 ambassadeurs par école et
par collège qui sont des
lanceurs d'alerte qui font remonter les
informations avec la formation de 5
adultes par école et par collège nous
avons d'ores et déjà des remontées
d'informations qui viennent des
rectorats qui indiquent la
généralisation que la généralisation de
ce programme est en cours par ailleurs
nous sommes très attentifs au phénomène
de cyber-harcèlement avec la
popularisation du numéro vert le 30 18
qui s'ajoute au 30/20 et nous avons
échangé hier aussi avec les responsables
de ce numéro vert bref les acteurs nous
mobilisons l'ensemble des acteurs c'est
un travail qui est un travail de longue
haleine qui demande la mobilisation de
tous y compris d'ailleurs des postes
d'infirmières et de psychologues il y a
des postes vacants en effet mais nous en
créons des postes de psychologue
scolaires qui s'ajoutent au travail
important que nous menons dans les
écoles et dans le collège pour faire
recluer ce fléau
juste pour vous dire Monsieur le
Ministre que je n'ai absolument pas dit
que la le programme phare était de la
répression j'ai bien précisé que la loi
prévoyait trop de répression à mon sens
pour peu d'éducation mais je n'ai pas
confondu les choses je vous remercie la
parole est à Monsieur Christophe Barthez
pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de la
Justice
216% 138 détenus pour une capacité de 64
places c'est le taux d'occupation de la
maison d'arrêt de Carcassonne où je me
suis rendu ce 28 octobre la prison la
plus surpeuplée de France devant Nîmes
et foi loin d'être une exception cette
prison est à l'image de notre système
carcéral nos agents pénitentiaires sont
en première ligne face à la
surpopulation des prisons conditions de
travail déastreuse crachats insultes
agression physique et ce quotidiennement
ils sont découragés épuisés physiquement
et psychologiquement ce constat est
simple trop de missions plus de dangers
trop peu de personnel une fois les
promesses envolées rien n'est fait pour
mettre hors d'état de nuire des
délinquants qui eux sont ensuite
relâchés faute de place suffisante
quel manque de naissance pour leur
victime vous essayez de recruter du
personnel mais vous échouez pour
développer l'attractivité de ce métier
qui est en fait une vocation il faudrait
un augmenter les salaires renforcer la
protection du personnel et arrêter de
reculer l'âge de départ à la retraite
monsieur le ministre avez-vous oui ou
non allez vous oui ou non mener une
politique de bon sens face à la
surpopulation carcérale allez-vous
expulser des tenues étrangers multiplier
les places de prison et répondre enfin à
la souffrance de nos agents je vous
remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
monsieur Éric Dupond-Moretti garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice
je m'attends maintenant chaque semaine à
une petite question sur le thème du
laxisme de la justice
en dépit des chiffres que je vous ai
donné et qui sont consignés dans les
débats notamment de la semaine dernière
mais que vous ne voulez pas voir vous ne
voulez pas les entendre bien vous êtes
quand même
paradoxaux les uns et les autres de ce
côté-là parce que vous me reprochez à la
fois le laxisme de la justice et la
surpopulation carcérale la surpopulation
carcérale c'est la première des
illustrations que la justice monsieur le
député n'est pas laxiste pour le reste
nous sommes en train de construire plus
de 15000 places de prison net
grâce à des budgets que nous sommes
allés chercher
avec toute la force de conviction dont
nous sommes capables et que vous n'avez
jamais voulu voter alors arrêtez vos
leçons de justice parce que quand il est
question de donner à la justice les
moyens dont elle est dont elle a besoin
quand il est question de donner aux
forces de sécurité intérieure les moyens
dont les forces de sécurité intérieure
de notre pays ont besoin vous n'êtes
jamais au rendez-vous de vos obligations
vous êtes Yaka vous êtes faucon vous
êtes faudrait et rien d'autre
strictement rien d'autre alors je vais
vous dire non seulement nous avons
embauché
4000 personnels supplémentaires mais
dans ce que nous mettons en place que
vous voudrez peut-être
j'en sais rien il y a 1500 magistrats
supplémentaires 1500 greffiers et il y a
10 000 personnels au total parce que
naturellement il nous faut du personnel
pénitentiaire je veux leur rendre
hommage troisième force de sécurité dans
ce pays j'ajoute que ce que nous avons
fait sur le plan social et notamment la
fusion des grades personne avant nous
monsieur le député de l'avait fait voilà
ce que je veux vous répondre
à Carcassonne vous n'avez pas mis du
personnel en plus mais à moins j'ai
visité des cellules avec cinq
prisonniers dans 15 mètres carrés non
seulement c'est dangereux pour la
sécurité de nos gardiens mais malgré un
travail formidable directeur de son
personnel cette person est une honte
pour la France une honte pour nous
parlementaire si nous laissons faire et
pour vous monsieur le ministre
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Charles Fournier pour le groupe
écologiste
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
vous vouliez une question des
écologistes sur la COP 27 je vous la
propose
dimanche depuis dimanche les regards
sont tournés vers Charmel chèque en
Égypte sous le haut patronage de
Coca-Cola qui produit 200000 bouteilles
de plastique par minute les dirigeants
de notre belle planète tentent de
trouver une issue au processus de
destruction qui est à l'oeuvre les cops
en elle-même ne servent à rien si les
dirigeants du monde n'agissent pas
concrètement la cop21 et les autres
coops n'auront servi à rien si des
décisions radicales n'auront pas été
prises le président de la République a
tenté au début de cette COP danser le
costume de l'élève climatique modèle à
l'entendre nous serions les seuls à
payer et à réduire nos émissions pire la
responsabilité serait ailleurs chez les
autres risquant d'alimenter
l'effectueuse c'est la faute des Indiens
des Américains et des Chinois nous
sommes habitués aux annonces en grande
pompe et au greenwashing l'écologie est
le combat du siècle la fin de
l'abondance et cette semaine on
s'adressant aux jeunes je suis comme
vous je n'aime pas les énergies fossiles
mais les actes ne sont pas alignés avec
les paroles par exemple Emmanuel Macron
et les énergies fossiles c'est un peu je
la parole est à Madame Bérengère
Couillard ministre chargé de l'écologie
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Fournier alors vous avez raison sur une
chose c'est qu'il est plus que temps
d'agir pour le climat mais aussi pour
pour la nature et jamais jamais une
majorité n'avait fait autant et n'était
allé aussi loin dans son ambition pour
le climat et pour la préservation de la
biodiversité depuis 5 ans le cap fixé il
est clair et ambitieux à la fois au
niveau national et aussi au niveau
international comme la Râpée le
président de la République à charmait
cher la bataille pour le climat et la
bataille pour la biodiversité sont les
deux faces d'une même médaille
l'objectif de Neutra de neutralité
carbone en 2050 est une boussole à
laquelle nous nous tenons et qui guide
nos politiques publiques pour décarboner
notre économie favoriser les énergies
renouvelables et également lutter contre
les énergies fossiles le président de la
République rencontre d'ailleurs
actuellement en présence de Christophe
Béchu les 5 et filière les plus
émetteurs afin qu'ils prennent des
engagements pour la décarbonation de
notre économie c'est une nouvelle étape
dans le renforcement de notre ambition
la France s'engage également à
l'international pour préserver notre
environnement et la biodiversité nous
porterons à la COP15 biodiversité un
objectif fort au niveau mondial celui de
protéger 30% des terres et des mers de
notre planète en 2030 c'est ce que nous
faisons ici avec la stratégie nationale
Air protégée et que nous soutenons et
nous souhaitons voir étendus pour les
océans tout particulièrement le
président de la République apporté un
message extrêmement fort celui de
soutenir l'interdiction de toute
exploitation des grands fonds marins et
la redit hier enfin une politique
efficace est une politique juste et
c'est pour cela que la France s'est
engagée à y consacrer 2 milliards
d'euros par an de 2021 à 2025 soit le
tiers de ses financements internationaux
en faveur du climat à elle seule la
France contribue à environ 10% de la fin
international dédié à l'adaptation
changement qui monte ce sont ces
engagements nationaux et internationaux
que nous défendons à la monsieur le
député
en deux secondes aux actes
monsieur Anthony Bros pour le groupe
Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur Clément Beaune
ministre délégué chargé des transports
monsieur le ministre ce jeudi 10
novembre suite à l'appel national
l'ancien fin octobre par la CGT des
mouvements de grève sont attendus dans
le secteur des transports notamment à la
SNCF et à la RATP des perturbations sont
attendues dans plusieurs grandes villes
comme à Rouen Montpellier mais aussi à
Orléans dans mon département les
habitants de nos territoires bien
éloignés de la capitale sont des
habitués des transports en commun plus
de 10 000 loire-rétains prennent ainsi
chaque jour le TER depuis la gare de
Fleury-les-Aubrais où le RER depuis le
malesherbois pour rejoindre Paris ce qui
ne sera pas sans leur poser de
difficultés pour se rendre sur le lieu
de travail ce jeudi car c'est bien en
Île-de-France que les liaisons seront
les plus impactées avec un objectif zéro
métro zéro RER mot d'ordre de 5
syndicats de la RATP
le revendications sont la hausse des
salaires des pensions de retraite ainsi
qu'une meilleure reconnaissance de leurs
qualification pourtant le gouvernement
est notre majorité n'ont pas attendu
pour se mobiliser pleinement sur ces
sujets primordiaux pour l'ensemble des
Français au-delà de la Loire en faveur
du pouvoir d'achat que nous avons adopté
cet été le ministère des Transports voit
son budget fortement augmenter l'année
prochaine vous avez vous-même mis la
priorité sur les transports du quotidien
et le développement du ferroviaire avec
une forte volonté de verdissement du
secteur appelé à s'accroître pour
décarboner nos usages les Français sont
attacés au 30 au transport en commun
attachés mais exaspéré par les
difficultés qu'il rencontre en ce moment
notamment en raison du manque de
conducteur et des rames bondées ainsi
Monsieur le Ministre pouvez-vous nous
indiquer ce que le gouvernement prévoit
de mettre en place afin d'améliorer la
qualité de service de nos transports du
quotidien je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à monsieur
Clément bonne ministre des Transports
madame la Présidente et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Anthony Bros
comme vous je veux d'abord avoir une
pensée pour beaucoup de nos concitoyens
en Île-de-France mais notre région de
France qui ont des difficultés
aujourd'hui particulièrement importantes
disons-le dans les transports du
quotidien il y aura un mouvement
national de grève jeudi il aura fort
impact sur le réseau francilien
notamment à la RATP moins à la SNCF et
je sais que cela vous leur dire des
galères supplémentaires pour beaucoup de
gens nous devons garder cette priorité
claire pour les transports du quotidien
pas par l'incantation mais par une
action très concrète vous l'avez rappelé
c'est ce que doit faire l'État et les
collectivités ensemble je le dis il faut
que chacun aussi fasse face à ses
responsabilités et que nous regardions
chaque situation de manière spécifique
pour répondre efficacement j'étais hier
à Lille dans les hauts de France j'ai
échangé avec le prénom de région Xavier
Bertrand j'échangera de prix en SNCF
encore les prochaines heures il y a là
une situation inacceptable où il y a une
mauvaise anticipation du nombre de
conducteurs nécessaires un manque de
recrutement nous devons accélérer je
vais demander à la SNCF et je
continuerai à m'engager pour cela aux
côtés de la région il y a ensuite en
Île-de-France une station qui est
différente j'entrerai pas dans chaque
détail la région à Réduit l'offre le
transport nous devons maintenant avec la
RATP redresser les choses je ne poserai
jamais jamais un service public qu'on le
rejette comme ça parfois en pâture dans
un débat car c'est la RATP qui doit
aujourd'hui qui s'engage pour améliorer
les choses et qui se mobilisent
activement pour améliorer les choses je
veux aussi leur rendre cette hommage et
nous devrons continuer à investir car
c'est comme ça que pour le transport
public nous résoudrons la situation
l'urgence et l'investissement jamais
nous l'avons investi autant dans notre
réseau de transport public le réseau
lui-même il n'avait jamais connu un tel
investissement au cours des 15 dernières
années est-ce que c'est suffisant est-ce
que nous sommes au bout du chemin
évidemment non mais je le rappelle dans
le budget qui a été soumis à votre débat
je m'en souviens pour avoir été
nuitamment avec vous c'est d'un milliard
d'euros ne serait-ce que pour le réseau
francilien qui est investi pour
développer de nouvelles lignes et
améliorer le réseau nous aurons un
rapport parlementaire dans peu de temps
celui du Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures il nous permettra de
documenter des actions des budgets pour
agir encore davantage car oui nous
devons faire plus ça se fait par
l'investissement par l'engagement et par
la réponse à l'urgence merci beaucoup
la parole est à Madame Stéphanie Galzi
pour le groupe rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Madame Rima Abdoul Malak
ministre de la Culture les attaques
contre les œuvres d'art au nom de la
cause écologique se multiplient ces
dernières semaines en Europe depuis le
14 octobre des activistes voire des
terroristes pour reprendre les termes du
ministre de l'Intérieur en sévit par
exemple à Londres à postman à La Haye à
Madrid ou encore à Rome des tableaux de
Van Gogh de monnaie de Vermeer de Goya
bref des œuvres d'une valeur
patrimoniale inestimable et dans la
perte serait irremplaçable ont été pris
pour cible la France et Paris ne sont
pas en reste le 30 octobre 2022 on
apprend dans le Journal de parisien
qu'une attaque similaire a été évitée de
peu au musée d'Orsay contrairement à
l'extrême gauche je ne prends pas ses
attaques à la légère je ne les justifie
pas je ne les excuse pas
certes elles sont ridicules puisque je
ne vois pas le rapport entre la soupe
hein les plus belles réalisations de
l'humanité et la sortie des
hydrocarbures mais justement c'est cette
absurdité qui doit nous interpeller
s'attaquer au chef-d'oeuvre de
l'humanité n'est ni anodin ni excusable
les pires totalitarisme ont un point
commun ils s'attaqua l'art et à la
mémoire
ils font table rase du passé il
détruisent les Forces Républicaines ne
peuvent se coucher devant la montée de
ces mouvements violents ma question
madame la ministre est donc la suivante
avez-vous pris conscience du danger qui
pèse sur nos musées quelles actions
avez-vous pris pour protéger la et la
culture de l'obscurantisme vert je vous
remercie
intérêt pour l'avenir de nos musées mais
s'agissant des œuvres d'art j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de m'exprimer ici même et
plusieurs fois dans les médias je suis
très préoccupée par ce phénomène que
j'ai appelé moi-même déco vandalisme
qui prend pour cible des œuvres avec des
vitres pour le moment mais on ne sait
jamais ça pourrait déraper vers d'autres
types d'oeuvres nos agents sont préparés
nous avons de manière assez rapide
discuter avec les musées préparer les
équipes à
déjouer certaines interventions ce qui a
été le cas à Orsay ce qui a évité
effectivement pour l'instant une attaque
à Paris nous restons très vigilants on
n'est pas à l'abri dans un pays
démocratique de liberté d'expression
d'autres types d'intervention de de ce
genre mais nos équipes dans les musées
sont pleinement mobilisés
et sur un plan plus vocal l'ensemble des
directeurs de musées s'expriment aussi
pour essayer de faire la différence
entre ces œuvres qui sont comme vous
l'avez dit des chefs de l'humanité que
nous transmettons de génération en
génération qui ont pour certaines
résister à deux guerres mondiales et
l'enjeu de la transition écologique qui
n'est pas à confondre avec l'attaque de
ses œuvres et selon lequel nous sommes
pleinement engagés notamment avec les
musées parce que eux aussi sont
concernés par la décarbonation et
l'amélioration de leur performance
énergétique je vous remercie je vous
remercie madame la ministre madame Galzi
très bien la parole est à Madame
Caroline seat pour la France insoumise
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de la Santé depuis le début de
la pandémie nous encourageons la
vaccination et nous privilégions la
stratégie convaincre plutôt que
contraindre en accord avec les
recommandations de l'Organisation
mondiale de la santé la situation dans
nos hôpitaux est très préoccupante nous
subissons une pénurie de personnel aux
urgences désormais la crise dans les
services de pédiatrie je viens moi-même
de recevoir une 24e 24e alerte d'appel à
la réserve sanitaire nos pompiers
rencontrent les mêmes difficultés après
un été particulièrement éprouvant dans
ce contexte chaque personne compte nous
avons donc déposé une proposition de loi
visant à réintégrer le personnel non
vacciné avec un protocole sanitaire
strict elle sera présentée
de la niche parlementaire de mon groupe
la France insoumise le 24 novembre
prochain dans le cadre des travaux de
cette proposition de loi nous avons
auditionné la Haute Autorité de santé
c'est représentants ont déclaré qui ne
s'opposerait pas ce qu'on réintègre ces
personnels suspendus puisque d'un point
de vue de santé publique ils ont jugé
sur et protecteurs le protocole
sanitaire que nous proposons dans notre
texte monsieur le ministre conformément
à la loi du 30 juillet 2022 vous devez
suivre les recommandations de la Haute
Autorité de santé ainsi ma question est
simple allez vous vous saisir de cet
avis favorable de l'âge as pour
permettre la réintégration de ces
personnels dont nous avons tous besoin
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur François Braun ministre de la
Santé de la prévention
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Caroline Fiat vous proposez de vous
inspirer d'une mesure surprenante
d'ailleurs du gouvernement italien de
Madame mélodie mesure qui
entraîne un certain nombre de
difficultés dans son pays actuellement
je tiens tout d'abord un rapporter comme
vous l'avez fait l'importance de la
vaccination la vaccination permet de se
protéger permet également de protéger
les autres et particulièrement les plus
faciles parce que contrairement à ce que
l'on dit ou ce que l'on peut penser le
covid tue encore et d'ailleurs depuis
que nous sommes dans cette hémicycle 10
de nos concitoyens sont décédés dans les
services de réanimation encore du covid
vous savez parfaitement comme moi que
les personnels non vaccinés leur
réintégration ne réglera pas les
problèmes de l'hôpital loin de là il
représente une minorité de ces
personnels et même cela va les aggraver
pourquoi parce que probablement comme
vous j'ai été interrogé les
professionnels sur le terrain et ses
professionnels sur le terrain sont
opposés à la réintégration des soignants
non vaccinés d'ailleurs les patients
eux-mêmes se sont exprimés dans le cadre
de France à sauce santé
concernant l'avis de la HAS je ne doute
pas de ce que vous en dit les gens de la
chasse mais à ma connaissance ils n'ont
pas fait de réponse officielle telle
question et je souhaiterais je pense que
vous serez d'accord avec moi que nous
puissions prendre un peu de distance des
passionnés et élargir le débat j'ai donc
demandé la saisie de la Haute Autorité
de Santé sur les consignes d'obligation
vaccinales des soignants de toutes les
obligations vaccinales celles qui
concerne les vaccins que l'on une ou
deux fois mais également celle qui
concerne les vaccins réguliers comme la
grippe et le covid par ailleurs cette
question est en une question sanitaire
mais également une question d'éthique se
protéger protéger les autres je vais
saisir le Conseil consultatif national
d'éthique également sur ces questions
nous aurons donc la vie de la SS et du
Conseil national des tiques
hier avec la HS j'ai eu le même souci
ils m'ont tout de suite répondu sur la
levée de l'obligation vaccinale quand je
suis arrivé sur notre proposition de loi
c'est-à-dire avec un protocole sanitaire
strict la vérité leur éclatée aux yeux
donc je suis ravie que vous demandiez
une saisie officielle la dernière fois
ils ont mis trois jours j'ose espérer
que ça fasse pareil ce coup-ci
rendez-vous le 24 novembre pour voter
cette proposition de loi qui ne fait que
bon sens le caricaturez pas nos propos
qui avait lieu merci
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe Brun
pour le groupe socialiste
ma question s'adresse madame la Première
ministre madame la Première ministre
votre projet d'OPA sur le groupe EDF ne
laisse d'interroger pourquoi en effet
dépenser plus de 9,7 milliards d'euros
d'argent public pour prendre le capital
d'une société qu'on contrôle déjà cette
question n'a reçu aucune réponse en tant
que rapporteur spécial de la commission
des finances de l'Assemblée nationale je
me suis rendu deux fois à Bercy deux
fois Bercy pour exercer mon pouvoir de
contrôle sur pièce et sur place j'ai
demandé des notes ou plan stratégique
actant l'abandon du sinistre projet
Hercule de démantèlement d'EDF et bien
figurez-vous mes chers collègues
qu'aucune n'existent j'ai pu consulter
des documents stratégiques confidentiels
qui démontre une toute autre réalité
dans une note du 27 juin 2022 que j'ai
pu consulter la montée au capital d'EDF
est présentée comme un moyen d'avoir les
mains libres pour je cite engager une
fidélisation de toutes ou partie des
activités du groupe liées à la
transition énergétique
suivi le cas échéant de leur
introduction en Bourse il est également
écrit mes chers collègues débutés par un
réorganisation du groupe enverrai un
signal négatif aux organisations
syndicales qui ne manqueraient pas de se
mobiliser dans les documents nombreux
que j'ai pu consulter j'ai pu constater
l'invention claire du gouvernement de
démanteler EDF une fois la
nationalisation terminée alors madame la
Première ministre ma question est simple
lorsque le gouvernement par la voie du
ministre de l'économie Bruno Le Maire le
22 juillet dernier à la tribune de cette
assemblée a affirmé que le gouvernement
garantirait l'unité d'EDF avez-vous
menti à la représentation nationale
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Gabriel Attal ministre chargé
du budget des comptes publics merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Philippe Brun je veux d'abord excuser
l'absence de Bruno Le Maire qui est à
Bruxelles pour une réunion de le
regroupe l'objectif de la montée à 100%
au capital de DF il est clair c'est
renforcé la politique nucléaire de la
France conformément au discours du
président de la République à Belfort qui
prévoit notamment la construction de si
EPR 2 tout ça pour assurer notre
souveraineté énergétique celle des
Français et de notre pays ça n'aurait
aucun sens de monter à 100% au capital
d'une entreprise comme EDF pour la
démanteler ou la vendre par appartement
ça n'est absolument pas le sujet et
Bruno Le Maire a déjà eu l'occasion de
dire que le projet Hercule n'était plus
à l'ordre du jour Monsieur le Député
vous avez exercé conformément à vos
prérogatives de rapporteur spécial votre
pouvoir de contrôle plusieurs pièces
vous êtes rendu à deux reprises à Bercy
les portes vous ont été ouvertes tous
les documents que vous avez demandé vous
ont été communiqués je vous vois aussi
la tête vous avez pu les cons vous avez
pu les consulter en toute transparence
que nous sommes très respectueux vous
avez eu accès à de nombreux documents à
des notes et les équipes de Bruno Le
Maire Bruno Le Maire Bercy est à votre
disposition pour vous répondre si vous
avez des questions sur certains
documents qui auraient été consultés moi
je vous rappelle l'objectif qui est le
nôtre c'est de conforter et de renforcer
EDF qui en a bien besoin pour être
capable d'assurer la souveraineté
énergétique de notre pays et j'espère
que vous nous suivrez dans cette voie
quand les débats auront lieu au
Parlement sur ce sujet
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur Brun monsieur le ministre je
vous renvoie à une note que j'ai pu
consulter du groupe de travail de
négociation avec la Commission
européenne sur les prix les tarifs
réguliers de l'électricité et dans cette
note figure 4 scénarios 4 scénarios pour
l'avenir de DF et dans ces quatre
scénarios le démantèlement d'EDF est
envisagé et pour toutes ces raisons nous
ne vous nous inquiétez vous devez faire
acte des transparences désormais et nous
appelons à une loi de nationalisation
qui permettra de fixer définitivement
l'avenir d'EDF je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-François
porteario pour le groupe horizon
s'adresse à madame la ministre chargé de
la vie associative il y a en France
c'est une estimation environ 1,3
millions d'associations actives donc 90%
fonctionnent sans salarié c'est à dire
uniquement grâce à leur bénévoles si le
secteur associatif est particulièrement
important dans notre pays on peut
s'interroger sur les conséquences des
crises qui se superposent depuis celle
de la pandémie du covid-19 une étude
récente pour France Bénévolat montre que
27% des bénévoles ont cessé de
rengagement pendant la crise sanitaire
et ce mouvement d'érosion se poursuit
puisque toujours selon la même étude 2
millions de bénévoles ont interrompu
leur activité au cours des deux
dernières années
dans ce contexte un grand nombre
d'associations peine à maintenir leur
niveau d'activité à cause notamment de
cette baisse de l'engagement alors sans
parler encore d'une crise du bénévolat
il y a des signes tangibles
d'essoufflement un phénomène de
déditement constaté par de nombreux élus
que j'ai interrogé dans la région
toulousaine et c'est probablement le cas
un peu partout en France ce phénomène
inquiète de nombreux maires car les
associations jouent très souvent un rôle
essentiel dans la vie de leur commune si
on ajoute que le nombre de créations
d'associations ralentis depuis une
dizaine d'années on peut s'interroger
sur l'avenir de ce secteur qui
interviennent dans de nombreux domaines
d'activités comme l'action sociale
humanitaire le handicap le sport la
culture et les loisirs
face à ces inquiétudes et pour espérer
endiguer le phénomène de désaffection
des bénévoles je souhaiterais savoir si
une évaluation de la situation va être
réalisée surtout si les mesures de
reconnaissance et d'encouragement de
l'engagement associatif sont envisagés
je vous remercie
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le députés portarieux
je commençais par vous remercier pour
votre question et saluer votre
engagement je connais votre
préoccupation pour l'avenir de la vie
associative en Haute-Garonne comme
partout en France vous avez raison de le
rappeler les bénévoles sont nombreux et
ils permettent au pays de tenir un
Français sur trois et bénévoles et être
bénévoles ces données ce que l'on a de
plus précieux au monde puisque ces
données notre temps qui ne reviendra
donc jamais par définition ces bénévoles
nous devons les encourager c'est
pourquoi la première ministre a souhaité
que je puisse travailler sur deux
grandes priorités la première c'est
valoriser l'engagement bénévole nous
avons lancé un tour de France du
bénévolat au cours duquel nous décernons
les médailles à ces bénévoles ces
figurent que vous voyez partout dans vos
circonscriptions et qui sont présentes
lors des événements et qui tiennent ces
événements avec leurs engagements
bénévoles et au-delà de ça nous les
écoutons nous venons à leur rencontre
pour co-construire les politiques
publiques de la vie associative alors
décerner une médaille c'est très positif
c'est insuffisant vous me direz ça tombe
bien nous ne faisons pas que cela nous
travaillons sur la possibilité de
transformer les années d'expérience de
bénévoles en diplôme ça s'inscrit dans
le cadre du travail mené par le ministre
du travail et du plein emploi Olivier du
soft et la ministre Carole Grandjean et
dans le cadre de ce que vous-même
mesdames et messieurs les députés
avaient voté pour faciliter développer
l'accès à la VAE la première ministre
m'a donc demandé de développer une
plateforme pour les bénévoles afin que
chaque bénévole en France puisse avoir
dans quel diplôme il peut s'engager et
comment il peut ainsi sanctionner son
expérience de bénévoles ça c'est pour le
champ valorisé maintenant j'ai une
deuxième grande priorité qui est la
simplification quand on est bénévole on
s'engage pas pour passer des heures à
remplir des paperasses on s'engage pour
son cœur d'activité sa passion son
métier pour faire ensemble avec les
autres c'est pourquoi nous ouvrons un
grand chantier de simplification de la
vie associative pour lutter contre cette
inflation de paper demander toujours aux
associations ce Tour de France du
bénévolat va permettre de les écouter et
j'ai hâte de venir à votre rencontre
avec les bénévoles dans vos
circonscriptions merci beaucoup madame
la ministre monsieur portariu
dans plus d'être plus de temps Monsieur
Laurent Pagny foot pour le groupe
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre chers et chers collègues
j'associe à cette question mon collègue
le député Jean-Félix Aquaviva il manque
aujourd'hui en France 230 000 places de
crèches pour satisfaire les besoins de
2,2 millions d'enfants de moins de 3 ans
permettez-moi de relayer ici dans cette
assemblée la colère des représentants
professionnels et syndicaux de la petite
enfance qui ont organisé une journée de
mobilisation le 6 octobre dernier que
nous disent-ils d'abord et c'est
essentiel il vous reproche d'avoir
permis par arrêter ministériel à des
personnes non qualifiées d'accéder par
dérogation à des emplois dans les
crèches de même votre décision de
baisser le taux d'encadrement pour
passer de un professionnel pour 5
enfants à 1% suscite la colère ainsi non
seulement les personnels ne seront pas
qualifiés mais ils seront aussi moins
nombreux à accompagner nos enfants
ce n'est sûrement pas en dégradant
davantage les conditions de travail de
ces personnels que vous créerez les
conditions de l'attractivité de ces
métiers en situation de pénurie au
contraire vous prenez le risque de
brader les qualifications des salariés
déjà en place et de voir des mesures
exceptionnelles de venir ensuite
permanente vous l'avez compris la
réponse immédiate certes que vous
apportez aux problèmes ne règlera pas la
question structurelle de pénurie car ces
difficultés de recrutement sont les
conséquences directes d'un manque de
reconnaissance qui passe qu'on le
veuille ou non par de meilleures
conditions de travail et par une
revalorisation des salaires enfin pour
anticiper sur les départs massifs à la
retraite les professionnels demandent
une augmentation immédiate et importante
des places en centre de formation
ma question sera donc très simple madame
la Première ministre comptez-vous
entendre l'inquiétude des parents et des
professionnels face à cet arrêté
ministériel qui prévoit le recrutement
de salariés non qualifiés comment
redonner de l'attractivité à ces métiers
sans tomber dans le nivellement par le
bas je vous remercie je vous remercie la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Christophe
ministre des Solidarités de l'autonomie
et des personnes handicapées
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
députés Laurent pagnyfus permettez-moi
pour commencer ma réponse de saluer
l'engagement exceptionnel et remarquable
de l'ensemble des professionnels de la
petite enfance qu'il exerce leurs
activités en crèche ou à domicile comme
le font les assistantes maternelles
j'étais encore avec elle ce matin
d'ailleurs pour évoquer l'avenir de leur
profession mais également le futur
service public de la petite enfance la
situation est difficile sur le terrain
vous l'avez dit et je n'ignore pas cette
situation je n'ai pleinement conscience
notamment du fait de cette pénurie de
professionnels qui frappe le secteur et
plus généralement tous les métiers de
l'humain la Caisse nationale
d'allocations familiale estime
d'ailleurs qu'il manquerait aujourd'hui
environ 10 000 professionnels de la
petite enfance pour remplir l'ensemble
des places en crèche l'urgence est là et
le gouvernement agit pour restaurer
l'attractivité de ces métiers en
travaillant sur la qualité de vie au
travail sur les parcours professionnels
sur la formation mais également sur les
salaires dès le 11 juillet j'ai réuni le
comité de filière petite enfance
rassemblant tous les représentants du
secteur pour valider la mise en oeuvre
de ses premières propositions j'ai ainsi
débloqué 2 millions et demi d'euros à la
fois pour créer un observatoire de la
qualité de vie au travail mais également
pour organiser une campagne de
valorisation et de promotion de ces
métiers le 22 septembre dernier j'ai à
nouveau réuni le comité de filière
petite enfance et j'ai annoncé que le
gouvernement était prêt à accompagner
financièrement des revalorisations
salariales pour les professionnels de
crèche j'ai donc invité l'ensemble des
représentants du secteur syndicat
organisation professionnelle à se réunir
et à entamer des discussions que le
gouvernement accompagnera quant à la 15
à votre question précise sur le décret
je voudrais simplement préciser qu'il
vient encadrer une dérogation qui existe
depuis 20 ans que j'ai souhaité
l'encadrer justement pour assurer la
qualité et la sécurité de l'accueil dans
les crèches notamment puisque en dans
une période de pénurie il y avait
beaucoup plus recours et qu'il est
strictement encadré et conditionner à de
la formation des professionnels merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre la parole
est à Monsieur Thomas rudigos pour le
groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
monsieur le ministre la lutte contre le
trafic de drogue est un enjeu majeur de
sécurité publique et un défi pour toutes
nos forces de l'ordre le gouvernement en
a fait une priorité un travail sans
relâche qui a conduit en 2021 à la
saisie de 112 tonnes de cannabis et 26
tonnes 26 tonnes de cocaïne police
gendarmerie ont également démantelé en
2021 275 points de Deal nous le savons
mes chers collègues ces réseaux de
trafiquants au moyen de plus en plus
colossaux rengaine gangrène certains
quartiers de nos villes et peuvent mener
à des situations totalement
incontrôlables comme nous pouvons le
voir au Pays-Bas actuellement avec
notamment la mise sous une protection
policière renforcée du Premier ministre
menacé d'enlèvement par des Nar
trafiquants en tant que rapporteur pour
avis de la mission sécurité pour le
projet de loi de finance 2023 la partie
thématique de mon rapport a porté sur
l'Office antique anti stupéfiant aux
fast créé le premier janvier 2020 il
s'agit mes chers collègues d'un modèle
de coordination travaillant aussi bien
avec les services territoriaux comme les
cross les cellules de renseignements
opérationnel sur les stupéfiants mais
aussi en coopération étroite avec les
organisations policières internationales
telles que Interpol Europole où les
Américains de la de 1 le démantèlement
de ces réseaux criminels exige une
mobilisation totale de l'ensemble des
administrations concernées par ces
enjeux que ce soit la police la
gendarmerie mais aussi les douanes et
leur enseignement pénitentiaire fin
octobre le travail acharné des agents de
l'ofast ainsi permis de démanteler un
très important réseau de trafiquants de
cocaïne agissant entre les Antilles et
la métropole et la sais de plus de 300
kg de cocaïne ma question monsieur le
ministre est la suivante face aux enjeux
de la loi d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur la locmi et avec la hausse
budgétaire de plus de 1,3 milliards
d'euros de votre ministère quel est
votre feuille de route spécifique contre
le trafic de stupéfiant je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le député la
parole est à Monsieur Gérald de Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Rudigoz permettez-moi d'abord de vous
remercier de votre rapport qui est de
évidemment le gouvernement élaboré au
mieux sa stratégie anti stupéfiant après
la création en 2020 vous l'avez dit de
l'ofast qui est à la fois un service de
renseignement du deuxième cercle nous
prenons le trafic de stupéfiants d'abord
comme un trafic qui mérite les moyens
des services de renseignement en lien
avec le ministère de la Justice et le
ministère des comptes publics et nous
avons démontré vous l'avez dit dans les
résultats extrêmement importants que
nous avons obtenu en un an que cette
façon nouvelle une sorte de DA à la
française de fonctionner a montré
d'excellents résultats et je veux en
plus des saisies que vous avez évoqué
signifier l'augmentation de 21% de
trafiquants interpellé et présenté
devant la justice et de 24% des trafics
souvent internationaux des mantelés vous
avez eu raison de dire que tout l'Europe
toute l'Europe est particul sont
concernés par les attaques des criminels
narcotrafiquants les Pays-Bas et la
Belgique et la France par son modèle
arrivent justement à résister à cela
mais évidemment demande des moyens
supplémentaires il y a aujourd'hui 190
personnes à l'offaces tout ministère
confondu vous aurez constaté que dans
les années qui viennent nous auront 230
personnes à l'office centrale et 475
dans l'ensemble des organes territoriaux
c'est à dire nous allons monter en
puissance de façon très importante dans
la lutte contre les stupéfiants je veux
aussi dire que la réforme de la police
nationale permet notamment de répondre à
la préoccupation que vous évoquez en
mettant davantage de moyens pour lutter
contre ces trafics qui utilisent les
nouvelles technologies nous pensons tous
au téléphone crypté je salueais
d'ailleurs police comme gendarmerie dans
les opérations Sky UCC ou au crochets
mais également le Dark web et aussi le
réseau international de drogue qui
méritent désormais d'avoir une nouvelle
organisation ministère de l'Intérieur
merci à vous de l'accompagner je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre la parole
est à Monsieur Michel Guignot pour le
groupe rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse aux ministres de la Santé le
31 mai 2022 le gouvernement vous a
demandé pour établir un ensemble de
recrutementations pour l'été et proposer
des axes de réforme pour notre système
de santé vous avez rendu votre rapport
le 30 juin et vous êtes devenu ministre
quatre jours après mon interrogation
porte sur une recommandation inquiétante
la disparition du médecin lors des
interventions du SMUR dans votre
recommandation numéro 20 vous envisagez
de vous reposer sur les praticiens
locaux lorsque l'équipe d'intervention
aura besoin d'un médecin un médecin
généraliste local devra-t-il abandonner
sa patientèle dans sa salle d'attente
pour pallier l'absence d'un médecin du
SMUR la recommandation numéro 22 décrit
clairement quand l'absence de médecins
urgentiste sur un territoire il sera
temporairement acceptable que l'équipe
d'intervention ne soit composée que d'un
ambulancier d'un infirmier est-ce
temporellement acceptable non dans ma
circonscription de l'Oise quand un
véhicule du SMUR non médicalisé
interviendra dans les zones rurales
éloignées il faudra jusqu'à 40 minutes
pour qu'un médecin arrive sur les lieux
j'ai apporté bien sûr mon soutien
personnel soignant et aux élus du noyau
né qui protestent je réitère ce soutien
ici à l'Assemblée nationale je salue les
efforts et les sacrifices qui sont
quotidiennement consentis par nos
personnels soignants que la nation
acclame et que le gouvernement accable
faut-il rappeler monsieur le ministre
que selon votre rapport aux
prescriptions devaient être temporaire
mais temporaire jusqu'à quand la réforme
de notre système de santé doit inclure
la représentation nationale alors que la
RS des Hauts-de-France précise que ce
système est déjà encore de déploiement
le gouvernement dont vous êtes membre a
l'habitude des passages en force vos
conclusions nous seront-elles aussi
imposées de force monsieur le ministre
quelle disposition envisagez-vous de
prendre en faveur des urgences de
l'hôpital public qui a déjà tant
souffert afin de limiter les dangereuses
dérives de votre rapport merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur François Brown
ministre de la Santé de la prévention
monsieur le député Guignot madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Député Guignot
madame et Messieurs les Députés je vous
remercie d'évoquer la situation des des
smurs cela me permet de rendre hommage
aux 750 000 interventions qu'il réalise
tous les ans par air par terre et sur
mer d'autant plus aujourd'hui ou je
tiens à déplorer fermement et a
condamner l'agression d'un médecin du
Smur de Gonesse qui a été victime de
coups qui lui ont été portés lors d'une
intervention ce matin
vous évoquez le rapport qui est issu de
la mission flash je profite pour
rappeler que j'avais annoncé dès le
départ que dès lors que cette mission
avait des résultats positifs il serait
perdu il perdrait il serait continué ce
qui est le cas et vous parlez de deux
choses qui sont différentes tout d'abord
les médecins correspondant de SAMU vous
parlez de ces médecins généralistes donc
les médecins correspondant de SAMU
existent depuis plus de 15 ans
maintenant ce sont les avant-coureurs du
SMUR il donne totalement satisfaction
ont permis de sauver des vies ils
interviennent soit seul soit en
attendant l'arrivée d'un SMUR dans des
zones ou le SMUR est éloigné ou quand le
SMUR est occupé les équipes
paramédicales de Médecine d'Urgence
puisque c'est de cela dont vous parlez
ces équipes paramédicales de médecine
d'urgence se relèvent du même principe
c'est une discussion qui est ancienne
avec l'ensemble des professionnels de la
médecine d'urgence et j'en sais quelque
chose elle a abouti cet été en
particulier dans le département de la
Sarthe et a montré là aussi ici c'est
total satisfaction dans ses actions
intervenant soit seul ou en avant-couare
du SMUR sous la surveillance sous la
compétence également du médecin
régulateur du SAMU c'est donc un
dispositif qui est amené à augmenter à
disposer dans d'autres territoires et
dans votre territoire en particulier je
tiens à préciser que cette travail sur
le PMU a été fait en concertation avec
le maire en concertation avec les
équipes du territoire et que cela permet
là aussi de maintenir des médecins
urgentistes dans les deux services
d'urgence concernés je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Louis Louis Boyard
pour le groupe la princesse soumise
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur il
y a 3 ans en novembre 2019 la précarité
étudiante explosée aux yeux du pays un
étudiant venait de s'immoler par le feu
devant le CROUS de Lyon il dénonçait son
extrême pauvreté celle de ses camarades
et l'inaction de l'État depuis ce drame
la précarité étudiante ne cesse
d'exploser face au fil d'étudiants
devant les distributions alimentaires
pourquoi l'action du gouvernement est
elle aussi pauvre qu’un sandwich du
CROUS
je vous remercie monsieur le député la
parole est à Madame Sylvie Retailleau
ministre de l'Enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche
madame la Présidente Monsieur et Madame
mesdames les députés monsieur le député
Louis Boyard d'abord je ne peux pas vous
laisser utiliser la précarité de nos
étudiants et laisser croire que le
gouvernement vous a attendu pour agir je
voudrais rappeler que dès le mois de
juin juillet nous avons mis 300 millions
d'euros de mesure d'urgence pour cette
rentrée et puis je ne peux pas vous
laisser croire que de la même façon
finalement que le gouvernement n'a pas
agi sur tous les volets sur les volets
de la précarité effectivement de tous
nos étudiants et que seul l'augmentation
de 4% des bourses était la réponse à
l'inflation je vous rappelle que nous
avons mis sur la table une aide
exceptionnelle de 100 euros pour plus de
la moitié des étudiants les APL de 3,5
ont augmentation et puis je voudrais
rappeler et répéter que pour tout
étudiant précaire même non boursier et
bien on s'adressant aux CROUS ils ont
droit au repas à 1 euro et donc
effectivement je vous incite au niveau
de tous les étudiants à les encourager à
s'adresser aux CROUS s'adresser aux
CROUS pour avoir des aides ponctuelles
plus que les mesures d'urgence nous ne
vous avons pas attendu non plus pour des
mesures conjoncturelles et des mesures
structurelles ces mesures structurelles
je les ai lancé le 7 octobre avec une
concertation avec l'ensemble des acteurs
pour l'ensemble des volets des étudiants
le logement la santé la restauration etc
et je voudrais vous dire que
effectivement comme je vous l'ai dit
quand nous nous sommes vus vendredi et
bien je défendrai un modèle solidaire
pour tous ceux qui en ont besoin que ma
porte reste ouverte pour travailler sur
un seul objectif cet objectif étant le
bien-être des étudiants et nous allons y
travailler dans cette concertation avec
l'ensemble des acteurs et les
organisations étudiantes aussi autour de
la table que je remercie voilà donc
c'est dans cette optique là que nous
allons continuer ce travail de fond dans
le gouvernement est responsable ce
travail de mesure structurelle sur les
mesures pour les étudiantes merci madame
la ministre monsieur Boyard
madame la ministre les étudiants ont
faim mais vous ne leur donnez que des
miettes alors que un étudiant sur deux
affirme qu'il ne mange pas à sa fin vous
osez vous vanter d'avoir augmenté les
bourses mais dans quel monde est-ce que
vous vivez les trois quarts des
étudiants ne touchent pas de bourse et
pour ceux qui ont touché une vous avez
augmenté les bourses de seulement 4%
alors que l'inflation est après de 6%
madame la ministre les calculs ne sont
pas bons sur la prétendue hausse des aPL
vous mentez encore après avoir baissé
les APL il y a 5 ans vous avez encore
fait des économies sur le dos des
étudiants les APL ont certes augmenté de
3,5%. mais les loyers ont eux aussi
augmenté de 3,5%. et je ne vais pas vous
la prendre le montant des loyers et
largement supérieur à celui des aPL
madame la ministre les calculs ne sont
pas bons vos mensonges sont contredis
par les files d'attente qui s'allonge
distribution alimentaire car aujourd'hui
être étudiant c'est être pauvre être
étudiant c'est souvent enchaîner les
galères et les petits boulots alors
quand si elle arrive comment parler
d'égalité entre ceux qui ont la chance
d'être aidé et les autres il y a
quelques jours dans votre réponse à la
vidéo de Maël cet étudiante qui survit
avec 100 euros par mois vous avez
affirmé que vous étiez déterminé à aider
les étudiants précaires et bien
aujourd'hui devant Maël qui est venu
vous écouter dans cette assemblée leur
est venue de le prouver madame la
ministre ma question est très simple le
24 novembre soutiendrez-vous notre
proposition de loi instaurant une
allocation d'autonomie pour que chaque
jeune puisse vivre au-dessus du seuil de
pauvreté le 24 novembre éradiquez-vous
la précarité
la parole
est à Madame Emmanuel Antoine pour le
groupe les républicains
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'Agriculture de 20 à 30 euros le
mégawattheure début 2020 à 800 euros le
mégawattheure en septembre dernier les
prix de l'électricité flambent cette
réalité vécue par l'ensemble des
Français affectent aussi nos
agriculteurs ce qui doivent renégocier
leur contrat de fourniture d'électricité
avant la fin de l'année sont accablés
par les tarifs auxquels ils se
retrouvent soumis leur facture est
multipliée par 5 x + avec de telles
hausses l'amortisseur électricité prévue
par le gouvernement ne suffira pas il ne
permettra de prendre en charge qu'un
quart a un tiers du surcoût énergétique
pour les exploitations du moins pour les
agriculteurs qui sont éligibles
certaines entités agricoles avec un
statut hybride ne sont effectivement pas
assurés de pouvoir bénéficier de cet
amortisseur énergétique par exemple le
syndicat d'irrigation de moi syndica
intercommunal qui gère une régie
d'exploitation mais malheureusement
éligible à aucune aide pourtant sa
facture énergétique va passer de 2
millions et demi d'euros en 2020 à 30
millions d'euros l'année prochaine ils
s'ensuit que le prix du mètre cube d'eau
qu'il facture aux exploitations pas plus
que quintuplé remettant en cause la
pérennité des exploitations agricoles la
nouvelle donne énergétique va entraîner
la faillite de nombreux agriculteurs
dans toute la France la production de la
ferme France sera réduite d'autant au
détriment de notre souveraineté agricole
et alimentaire les exploitants devront
répercuter leur nouvelle charge
énergétique sur leur prix au détriment
de la compétitivité de notre agriculture
cela favorisera les importations au
détriment de nos productions locales
cela mettra en difficulté l'emploi
agricole et la logique des circuits
courts tant défendus monsieur le
ministre les agriculteurs ont besoin que
la hausse des prix de l'électricité soit
plafonné à 120 mégawattheure pour que
leurs exploitations restent viables
alors allez-vous leur garantir à tous la
protection dont ils ont besoin
énergétique je vous remercie la parole
est à Monsieur Marcelo ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire merci madame la Présidente
merci de votre question qui vous
permettent de rappeler un certain nombre
de dispositifs qui ont été portés par le
gouvernement je ne dis pas les
dispositifs qui ont été portés au moment
de de l'inflation en particulier sur les
produits de l'alimentation animale ça ne
sont plus de 500 millions d'euros qui
ont été développés pour faire face à ces
difficultés remontons nos agriculteurs
et nos industries agroalimentaires vous
rappelez qu'il y a trois dispositifs en
plus de ceux qui ont déjà été disposés
pour un certain nombre d'entreprises qui
sont des leviers le bouclier tarifaire
pour les petites entreprises très
petites entreprises l'amortisseur
électricité vous en avez parlé pour les
TPE et le guichet gaz électricité pour
les entreprises les plus énergos
intensives et un certain nombre
d'agriculteurs qui sont concernés par
cette question vous avez raison c'est un
sujet de souveraineté et au travers de
ces dispositifs nous faisons en sorte de
pouvoir aux côtés des agriculteurs des
industries agroalimentaires faire face à
cette hausse des coûts énergétiques qui
posent effectivement à terme si nous
n'essayons pas de le résoudre des
problèmes de souveraineté vous posez la
question de votre syndicat intercommunal
de la Drôme comme vous l'avez dit je
sais pas si le terme hybridé bon en tout
cas il a un statut complexe qui fait
qu'il ne peut pas rentrer aujourd'hui
dans le dispositif tel qu'il est connu
nous y travaillons avec Bruno Le Maire
avec les services de Bercy pour essayer
de trouver une solution l'objectif nous
avons déjà traversé une compréhension
d'autres crises pense à la crise covid
on sait que parfois les dispositifs ne
sont pas calibrés pour des statues qui
sont des statuts particuliers mais nous
allons y travailler parce que comme vous
le dites c'est un syndicat qui a des
effets très importants et qui a des qui
est une nécessité très importante pour
les agriculteurs de la Drôme je sais à
quel point ils ont besoin d'eau dans les
différentes productions qu'ils ont le
maraîchage et d'autres types de
production et donc nous allons faire en
sorte de pouvoir faire en sorte pardon
que ce syndicat puisse rentrer dans ses
dispositifs et je vous propose d'y
travailler comme nous y travaillons
aussi avec Bernard but le sénateur de la
Drôme qui nous avait aussi alerté sur
cette question je vous remercie je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre la parole
est à Madame Blandine brocard du groupe
démocrate
merci madame la Présidente
il faut que vous ayez conscience de la
chance qui vous est faite il y a autre
chose que les conneries ce que vous êtes
venu faire ici c'est quelque chose
d'utile pour vous ainsi vous
exprimez-vous il y a quelques mois
monsieur le garde des sceaux en visite
au camp militaire de couette quidan où
étaient mené une expérimentation
d'encadrement par d'anciens militaires
de six mineurs délinquants du centre
éducatif renforcé d'Évreux une chance il
s'agit bien de cela un redressement que
j'entends dans le sens de retrouver ou
de découvrir un droit chemin autre que
celui des conneries et de la récidive un
chemin qui Martel les valeurs fièrement
portées par nos militaires rigueur
abnégation discipline dépassement de soi
et de transmission
durant cinq semaines ces jeunes ont
suivi un stage de pratiques intensive
d'activité militaires en plein air Milan
marche secourisme formation de
généchologique découverte du monde
militaire et accompagnement à
l'insertion professionnelle
installé par exemple un bivouac en plein
hiver après avoir effectué une marche de
20 km un exercice qui fait partie du
quotidien de l'entraînement de nos
militaires ce ne sont pas les travaux
forcés à Cayenne mais c'est une manière
de souder les hommes de se dépasser de
réaliser qu'on est capable de solidarité
d'esprit de groupe et d'entendre
cordiales j'ai pu lire ici ou là que le
résultat du stage avait dépassé les
espérances qu'en est-il monsieur le
ministre pouvez-vous nous donner un
bilan de cette expérimentation des
écueils rencontrés
sans pour autant ignorer les difficultés
qu'il y aurait à solliciter
particulièrement nos armées qui sont
avant tout et peut-être plus que jamais
un outil de défense de notre nation
pouvez-vous nous dire votre volonté de
continuer d'étendre et de généraliser ce
type de dispositif monsieur le ministre
je sais que vous êtes fondamentalement
attaché à trouver de multiples solutions
pour nos jeunes qui sont en marge de
notre République alors pour ces jeunes
qui sont aussi les citoyens de demain
que proposez-vous je vous remercie la
parole est à Monsieur
Eric Dupond-Moretti garde des sceaux et
ministre de la Justice merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames Messieurs les
Députés madame la député Blandine
brocard d'abord je sais votre total
engagement pour lutter contre la
délinquance des mineurs c'est également
l'engagement du député Blanchet le
président de la République
lors de la campagne de la dernière
campagne a dit qu'effectivement nous
allions renforcer le partenariat
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse et
armée parce que j'avais mis en place une
expérience à couette qui dans qui a très
bien fonctionné au fond des jeunes qui
étaient dans un centre éducatif renforcé
sont allés
chercher auprès des militaires une
autorité que je qualifie de
bienveillante faut se lever le matin il
faut se dépasser il y a les valeurs de
la solidarité tout ça c'est important
pour des gamins qui sont à la dérive
alors voyons moi je le dis une fois
encore promettre la délinquance 0 c'est
de la flûte
c'est de la flûte en revanche
tout faire mais absolument tout
pour qu'il y ait le moins possible de
récidive et pour que ces jeunes
retrouvent le chemin de la vie civile
ordinaire ça ça nous oblige qu'est-ce
que nous avons fait déjà nous pas tout
le monde nous codes de justice pénale
des mineurs et ça marche on les juge
maintenant dans des temps très rapides
on construit des centres éducatifs
fermés je suis allé inaugurer le 53e il
y a quelques jours de cela 75% des
jeunes qui s'y trouvent
connaissent une sortie de la délinquance
et ils ont un projet professionnel qu'il
met en oeuvre et 86% d'entre eux
entendaient bien 86% d'entre eux ne
récidivent plus ça c'est le travail que
nous avons mis en œuvre collectivement
dans de la co-construction alors
maintenant
il faut aller plus loin merci Monsieur
et nous allons signer dans les semaines
qui viennent ce partenariat que vous
appelez de vos vœux je vous remercie la
séance est levée